area with myself
sara garvey and just pearly things the
woman that's lighting up the manosphere
right about now um
today's subject okay is
broken women equals a broken society but
before we even get started you guys
already know if you have watched
two or more
of our videos tell them and you haven't
subscribed uh-huh then what have we got
pearl beef what we got beef okay
all right so you better get subscribing
right pal over to you
okay guys we have an important
announcement today so first of all we
have dropped eclipse channel so
go subscribe to our clips channel you
guys have been begging for one and we
finally have one going so if you want
daily clips
from the show on top of the content we
already produced sign up for the clips
channel on top of that we have a twitch
page a facebook page and go follow my
instagram just dot pearly things all
super chats during the show will be read
and before
before we wanted to get issue camera but
today drum roll please
the man the myth the legends
ish
i appreciate you all thank you um yeah
let's get back to the show
so thank you all so much for all the
donations the past like what two months
we've been raising for this camera we've
officially got an issue camera you can
see the man behind the camera um we
would like to get one more camera in
here so
so send super chats for that
i would like one more
but today we have a lovely panel so why
don't we go around everyone say your
name your age your relationship status
and a fun fact
so you start hey my name is jay johnson
i'm 24.
i'm single a fun fact
i've been a musician since i was eight
years old okay
um hi my name is simona kudafani i'm 23
i'm single and
fun fact i'm a professional tarot card
reader
yeah
hello my name is georgia i'm 23 and i'm
single um
my special fact is my birthday is
christmas eve oh
yeah hi everyone my name is sophia i'm
25 years old i am single and my fun fact
is um i've been to san diego comic-con
18 times
uh so big comic book nerd over here
nice
hello everyone i'm harry i'm 24. i'm
single and i'm a big fan of socks
all the patterned socks
make i like them odd
as well
fair enough
all right so
today's topic
broken women equals broken society we're
going to get into it everyone's probably
thinking what do you mean don't worry we
get into it but what do you mean sarah
we we shall see we shall see
we have a video that we're gonna play
short little clip i haven't seen it yet
good yeah i'm excited good we're gonna
play this video clip and
we're gonna get your thoughts on it
and then we'll get talking about it so
um ish
the short the short video
um we're going to play that see what the
audience think of it you guys are going
to see it pearl's going to put it on
here yeah i have it up on her laptop ish
when you're ready
gas station
let him cream pie me and then i came
home to sneak into bed my boyfriend woke
up and then wanted to [ __ ] me and he
started eating me out and told me how
good my [ __ ] tastes and he's eating my
ex's come out of me and i never told him
funky dog head [ __ ]
once my boyfriend was asleep so i wanted
to go [ __ ] my ex real quick so i drove
down to the gas station let him cream
pie me and then i came home to sneak
into bed my boyfriend woke up and then
wanted to [ __ ] me and he started eating
me out and told me how good my [ __ ]
tastes and he's eating my
so as you ladies and gents saw
this lady um
was with her boyfriend uh ex called her
she met him at the gas station she had
sex with them ex at the gas station
he creampied her as she said she went
back to her boyfriend her boyfriend ate
her out and said she tasted great
no what do we think of that video before
you even get into it that's bold
it's why
it's actually green i feel so good
well i mean apparently he didn't because
she tasted great
i mean unless she told him and just
submitted that from the story but i
don't think so but i'm very confused as
to why you meet at the gas station
why are you [ __ ] there there's lights
everywhere there's petrol
yeah that's right people you'd think
you think you mean at like a motel right
like at least
surely you just go around his house yeah
yeah well i guess maybe maybe he had a
girl too
oh god maybe it was like mutual that is
i'm shaking that's like you know she's
not above it he's probably not above it
right so what do you think
i mean i just think
go on
i think maybe this stuff happens
more often than it said
but you just never know you know this is
a very specific situation
but i've never heard it before so i have
a question um have any of you ever
cheated no yeah no no
so no so now have any of you ever
witnessed a friendship
no no
yes yes yes
no no okay
so you see like
that's a pretty
outrageous clip right but for me she was
bold enough
to go into like a podcast and say that
type of stuff
so
women like this right the reason why
this um episode is called broken women
broken society
women like this raise children
right eventually right how do you know
um if she went if she goes to have
children um
for me this type of psychology
and the way in which is so easily um
it's so easy to cheat and be like
quote-unquote sexually liberated to the
point of i think to the detriment of
society
um
[Music]
what do you think if the women of this
society continue to go down this road
how do you think society is going to end
up
i don't think you can say like women i
can i think you can say that one person
yeah i was about to say it went viral
because it's not normalized like if it
was normalized everyone just said oh
yeah that's fine yeah like i don't think
anyone here was like oh yeah would you
last week would you say by and large
women are getting more promiscuous
though than like 100 years ago yes but
like it's the whole like sexual
liberation but it comes with the whole
fact that we've been like repressed for
our sexuality for so so long and so now
it's kind of but also kind of mostly
appreciated for sexuality and there's
this like distorted divide where we're
not allowed to be sexual but also we're
expected to be sexual
and so like sexual liberation is
essentially reclaiming the power back on
that so doing things like that but i
guess it's a bit distorted just because
it's such a gray area
you know i feel like
what you said is like perfect
but i feel like this woman didn't do it
in the name of sexual liberation she's
just one random really weird person i
don't think she did it in the name of
this is for women this is for sexual
liberation this is for you know i think
she's just
don't you think sexual liberation has
led to women doing stuff like this
feeling more free to do it yeah i think
it's all it's probably always happened
it's just like
they're more vocal about it now and like
statistically like the generation before
us were actually a lot more sexually
sexually promiscuous than our generation
we're actually like no one's
can't swear no one's holding hands in
bed anymore like compared to them
they're like no one's [ __ ]
yeah that's fine
but now it's like more accepted that
like you just go online and like you can
just go viral for anything so you're
going to say the most out loud on this
stuff like she might not have even done
that right yeah she might have just said
it's like i want to be famous yeah but i
don't know but it's possible this kind
of stuff has happened i mean it's
definitely happened i would say at least
once yeah so
but to both genders
oh yeah i mean it goes both ways but the
thing is that typically if you look at
the sexlessness stats of our generation
it's usually the men that are sexless
it's not the women
yeah one out of three men under 30 is a
virgin or hasn't had sex in the past
year okay so like usually when you look
at those stats like actually women are
having sex with more people and men are
having sex with less because it's a
smaller and smaller percentage of men
that are having sex with all the girls
yeah because women choose who assets so
yeah because like the more the more
girls sleep around like typically they
sleep up like they date up and so it
just becomes a smaller and smaller
percentage
do you think sexual liberation has
helped the western world or hindered it
in what way
um in the models of the the moral fabric
of society do you think it's helped it
or hindered it i think there was always
sex but it was always far away from us
so it was like magazines tv
media and whatever but it's now normal
for just a normal person to be like
super sexy and it's not
you know but i think
i think it helps i would say it depends
on what you're trying to accomplish
really i think we're still working
towards sexual liberation i feel like
there's still so many restrictions
around it that even when you are
sexually liberated you still have such a
backlash you still have so many people
um attacking you just because you can
have the freedom to do what you want it
doesn't mean you don't get the
repercussions of it and i think that's
still there so i don't think we're
really
sexually liberated because we still have
that judgment on it yeah repercussions
is just like a natural law of nature
it's not yeah it's not like people are
saying
it's about judgment in it it's about
people judging obviously it's not a
great situation that's pretty messed up
but well in my opinion um
sorry i lost my train of thought
i think i think the difference between
this and then a woman just being
sexually liberated and shaggy she wants
is
there's
that you're lying to someone here and
it's it's not
okay to do that to someone and i think
that's what is so
shocking like if she was just like oh
yeah my boyfriend lets me go sit with my
ex
in the gas station he's really kind
about that like and then he'll eat me
out into it then i'll be like yeah go
girl like you found someone who accepts
what you're into
like
so i agree with that but also like you
you don't do that to people that's awful
and then you brag about it like what
but then isn't that what sexual
liberation is isn't it about being able
to have sex and be free and tell people
look i'm allowed to have sex i can do
what i want as a woman i can have sex
with who i want the way i want if it's
open and honest and if both people are
in on it but in like that situation it
seemed like the guy wasn't in on it so
in that case like yeah don't you think
sexual liberation hurts women though in
the end in what sense
so like women that sleep with more
people have higher rates of depression
they're more likely to be on um
anti-depression drugs drugs and the more
people they sleep with the less likely
they are to have a happy marriage so i
think that comes sorry and um so
basically like when you the more women
are sleeping around it's like a smaller
percentage of men get to have sex with
all the girls and so it's like you're
basically a side chick
no because you you get a lot of data
from like dating apps yeah so you can
really see where few people are sleeping
with i would i would say that that that
boom and kind of like sexuality
especially in like women is is more kind
of like a time thing where we haven't
really been able to be that open with
our sexuality and that free with our
sexuality especially like as soon as
like 30 years ago there were still so
many restrictions on that so many
expectations and we're only now breaking
past that expectations where it has to
go so much further the other way before
it can be brought back a little bit so i
think it's people chasing that because
they think that's what's going to bring
them that fulfillment just because they
don't know they haven't explored that
they haven't had the opportunity to
explore that before so how much time do
you think needs to pass because birth
control was developed in the 70s um in
the u.s at least that's when roe versus
wade was passed which i know is
overturned now
but but that's still a lot of time like
that's longer than i've been alive yeah
like so my whole life like we've been
liberated you know
i think when it's not
like a systematic thing so like back in
the day the further back you go the more
sort of worse it is so that women have
never been sort of integrated into
society in a way of like
i don't know i lost my jacket
do you mean in the sense that they
weren't able to vote
yeah yeah yeah so
i think what i'm trying to say is um
before it was so bad now it's like
okay and we need to get it like perfect
and i think even if there's like kind of
legal restrictions that have been
removed there's still a lot of
conservative spaces where sexuality
isn't really free and it still affects
this generation like our parents
generation who like for example my
parents are catholic or come from
catholic backgrounds and there's a very
conservative mindset there where sex
wasn't talked about i wasn't even talked
to about my period
when i was a kid so even though like
legally and kind of in the like social
world yes that still were past that i
think it still like affects us
generationally even like our generation
where we're still getting that flack
from being sexually open and we still
don't really know how to navigate that
space wouldn't you say the internet
though is the great equalizer because
any information you really want is
available
so
like i've had a smartphone since i was
in eighth grade so if i really i was a
pretty innocent kid to be honest and it
didn't like i was fine with that yeah
but like
honestly if i wanted to google something
it's it's pretty easy it's right there
i was uh completely but i think it it's
social media is kind of like um a
detached way of looking at things i
think when you learn certain patterns
from your parents certain mindsets when
you learn not to talk about certain
things like i was sexual quite early on
just because of my family dynamic but i
received a lot of shame for it and i was
shamed for kind of the way i was acting
and it wasn't necessarily a healthy
thing but because it wasn't spoken about
it and it was kind of shut out i didn't
really learn how to deal with it
healthily what do you mean by shamed
um
so i found myself in a lot of kind of
quite sexual situations early on um that
was kind of the way i searched for
physical intimacy because i didn't
really know how else to do it it was
kind of the way
um and i received
a lot of backlash content from people
who found out about it like
teachers friends and friends of parents
who didn't want the kids to be friends
with me because i was sexually active
my mom never really spoke to me about it
but i could feel kind of that
disappointment in her so it's never like
outright but it's more like a shutout
you're kind of freezed out for acting a
certain way that doesn't really
um go with those conservative values do
you do you feel like we should be
encouraging young girls to be more
sexual i think we should encourage the
conversation about it okay i think
that's the issue the issues that we
don't talk about it it's not necessarily
encouraging girls to be more sexual but
knowing that if they have certain urges
if they have certain feelings if we can
know about it and have that conversation
about it because you can learn all types
of stuff from the internet right it's a
great place to find information but it's
also a great place to find
misinformation and so i think it's just
important to be having that conversation
about it and who do you think the one
that should be should be initiating that
conversation
do you think it should be parents do you
think it should be schools
um i think it should be collective
society i think we should all be
encouraging that conversation i don't
think it should be a taboo topic to be
talked about i think we should be
speaking about it completely because i'm
of the opinion that i think you can
judge a society by the way
the women act in that society i think if
you go to different nations around the
world and you look at the how the women
act in that society you will generally
get to know how the society is i feel
like the in the western world
the way the women act in this western
world you can kind of tell that society
is
degenerating in my personal point of
view i really do believe that it's
degenerating and that's because
for me
children have to be raised and they have
to be raised by someone so
women are the first teachers of children
so are the fathers and fathers no the
first teachers of children are women
because that's where the child is at
mostly it's mostly with the woman so
it's getting most of its teaching most
of its nurturing from the woman and if
the woman is not right
then the child's not going to be right
but it depends what you define as right
like yeah yeah yeah well morally correct
right
um a morally functioning fully
functioning
uh
part of society i think if i think if
the mothers and the women of the society
aren't functioning correctly then that
will be handed down quite easily to the
children but you're you're trying to
define what's morally correct for every
woman ever
like it's not the same as for everyone
else you know it's it's not about what's
morally correct it's just like actions
have consequences right and men are
biologically like they're repulsed by
girls that have slept around and that
they can't help it because historically
they had to ensure paternity so you can
you can't make that go away in them
so you say like the same way the same
way sorry the same way like we want a
tall guy because we wanted a guy that
could protect us you can't get rid of
our biology it's just there and like no
matter how much society tries it's it's
still there no guy wants to date a girl
that's slept with like 100 dudes i feel
like there are some guys 100 there are
people who don't have an issue
but if you if you okay there are
exceptions but it's not the rules
right okay
let me just let me just go around do you
want to date a girl that slept with 100
dudes no thank you do you want to date a
girl that slept with 100 dudes do you
want to date a girl that slept with 100
dudes no and i've asked this i've asked
similar questions on the show like i've
used different numbers 50 70 whatever it
is you can't
shame men into wanting what they want
it's it shouldn't be about what the men
want in that sense we shouldn't define a
woman's sexuality by what the men want
yeah we shouldn't define a woman's like
freedom to explore her sexuality about
what men want
right so you can you can do like i don't
care what other people do i don't think
it makes you a bad person just because
someone sleeps around like that's that's
what they want to do but
the point is there's consequences and so
if you sleep with a lot of people less
less guys want to date you but it's the
judgment and the taboo of sexuality that
that comes from kind of thinking that a
woman is dirty because she slept around
so much when that shouldn't be the
mindset but that's the mindset that's
been taught because of sexuality but
woman has been so controlled and
restricted and defined like marilyn
monroe who was a sex icon but it was in
so many different relationships where
the men were awful to her because they
took advantage of advantage of her
sexuality wanted her to be the sexual
icon but she also profited she also
profited off of it yeah so so you can't
say like she committed suicide because
of her relationship with the kennedy
brothers
of society our family
if anything that that's showing that
like being promiscuous doesn't lead to
good things right but it wasn't it
wasn't so convincing that led to it it
was the men that she was involved with
that she chose to be involved with so
it's like you if you make choices there
are consequences
and actually molested as the kids and
that's why she was like that
she was she was sexually molested as a
child i'm not i'm not if someone's if
that happens to someone that's terrible
i'm not blaming that on her but i'm
saying as an adult she made choices and
there were consequences and i have a lot
of empathy i think that's very sad she
may so for example she had a
relationship with tennessee williams who
she made the choice to be in a
relationship who she wanted to be in a
relationship with he saw her as this
ideal woman that he wanted because of
her sexuality but when he was with her
he wanted her to be like the madonna
[ __ ] complex he wanted her to be the
monado but she didn't fit that and so he
was horrible to her as a result and then
and left her and she made a choice to
love but because of her sexuality she
wasn't
okay i don't know what you're talking
about the madonna works oh sorry i don't
know i don't know divide the feminine
into like the virgin and the [ __ ] like
mary magdalene and mother mary that sort
of thing it's how we separate the
feminine in order we separate things we
don't understand it's weird to think
that women can both be that purity and
that's sexual well i mean like my point
is you pick who you date so like
if you keep finding yourself in toxic
relationship after toxic relationship
you have to look at yourself i don't i
don't know anything about marilyn monroe
i'm not going to pretend to be like the
expert on i don't know what she did in
her life but my only point is like
actions have consequences and i don't
care what people do but just don't
complain about the consequences the
consequences of
a
let's say more sexually liberated
society is that
all societies most societies and most
nations are built off a core
family nuclear family structure okay the
west seems to be straying more away from
a nuclear family structure and so
if the men are building their society
right generally men build societies
women nurture what's in the society
so if the men are building the society
and women are nurturing what's in
society and like i said the women aren't
right and we need a nuclear family
structure yet and still this
this um society teaches women to be
independent you don't need a man you can
do it all by yourself okay that is going
to um affect the moral fabric of the
society in which we live in but if you
make the point about women making bad
choices about partners if they stop
making those choices then they're wrong
for making the choices not to be with
partners who are going to be horrible to
them wait because to say that
so because of feminine sexual liberation
they don't need a man they become
independent that's yeah yes but it's
come from a space where women make
choices to be with the wrong men so they
decide to make different choices to be
independent to not pursue those options
so then what's what's the right choice
so you're saying that they made that
choice because of
so so in in this situation where monroe
made the decision to be with those
toxic just as an example not her
specifically but made that choice to be
in those toxic relationships and and now
we're on the other side where women are
choosing to be independent choosing not
to be in those toxic relationships
rather choosing to support themselves
then rely on someone who's going to
ultimately harm her
well
she made those choices to be with those
women but that's what i'm saying so are
choosing to be on their own
but why are you yeah why are you acting
like those are the only two options like
why why is that why are the only why are
the only two options pick a bad guy or
be by yourself because some people don't
actually have a choice
i think i think
a lot of women so when i think about my
grandma or
you know the men that she was dating
whatever
um
at that time you didn't really have a
job if you're a woman it wasn't really
you basically forced not to basically
and then the men that came to you were
your options right she had two options
both were not very nice men and once you
get into a relationship you can get you
can fall in love with a narcissist and
you could be amazing and then you marry
them and then they just
every single day and without any
financial freedom or independence you
can't leave
right so in this society it's like look
you could leave today you could get a
job yeah i mean just because don't like
your options you could get a job in the
past but what you're saying is with a
nuclear family the woman stays home she
doesn't go to work she's not independent
that's kind of what i'm hearing maybe
that's not what you meant but if a woman
can't be financially independent and
free then
some people don't actually have that
choice in being able to leave a violent
relationship i'm not saying girls can't
be financially independent like they
could they can go be financially
independent but what i'm saying it's not
conducive for families right so like
kids it's better for a thumb to have a
mom and a dad in the home right that's
incredibly hard to normal or
heteronormative as well right there's so
many sorry what's heather i don't know
sorry as in like um
straight couples right there's so many
different family dynamics that can like
supportively and genuinely raise the
kids so so i will say on this show we
try to stick to the rule rather than the
exception and that's not the majority
i'll get to the rule i'll get to the
rule 63 of youth suicides yeah are from
single mother homes ninety percent of
homelessness and runaway children are
from synchrony you can't put that on the
mother eighty-five percent of children
who show behavioral disorders are from
single mother homes eighty percent of
rapists with anger problems are from
single mother homes seventy one percent
of high high school dropouts are from
single mother homes 70 of youths in
operated institutions are from single
mother homes 80 percent of all the
youths are in prison are from single
mother homes
guys why is your immediate reaction
you're blaming the woman when he's just
reading a stat because i think wait
where this conversation was going was
like you know what women need to behave
and women need to act correctly and then
life would be sweet
they've been more nuclear families like
that's not the case there's a lot of
relationships that don't work and for a
lot of women the best situation they can
like they can give to their child to say
i'm going to leave this man
you know what
that's not true women leave 70 to 80 of
the time i'm pretty sure now it's 80 and
if you're college educated it's 90 so
women are the ones leaving
and and the other thing is like the
reason the reason i would put it on the
woman is because you pick who you have a
baby with
so so
okay okay okay so
we're in the uk now right and abortion's
legal up to six months yeah you pick who
you have a baby with
you're you you get an out but what if
you have a baby with someone believing
that they're a genuine person that
they're going to step up and then they
choose in my experience that's the
exception it's not the rule because what
i see is girls see the red flags early
on they keep dating him and then it goes
poorly and they're crying later but it's
like you saw the 10 million red flags
before you had the kids there's so many
different things involved in not seeing
red flags there's so many different
mental health issues there's so many
different societies there's so many
excuses
but there's a reason for it there's a
reason that's an excuse
it doesn't mean it's not justified sound
like you have a lot of excuses for women
i don't have excuses for women i haven't
understand what women have been through
to me is just taking care of you
i think the conversation is like you're
trying to say it's everything's really
black and white yeah this is the reason
why women leave
all the time like they're so
relationships are so complex that
looking at a stat you can't be like okay
well it's women's fault they need to
behave yeah but the results is what
matters
what matters is not your feelings what
matters is the results at the end of the
day and so if the results are a certain
percentage of women 80 are leaving
marriages your feelings don't come into
the situation because what's happening
is because everyone's going to have
different feelings right
this woman said it was because that
reason that woman said it because it's
that reason it was because of this but
at the end of the day the result is it's
80 of women leaving marriage
and at the end of the day it's the kids
who suffer because you're putting your
feelings above the kids and this is i'm
taking out exceptions like abuse outside
outside of abuse you're putting your
your feelings above the children do you
not think if men behave better women
would stay because women and now you
know you have to be responsible you have
to get a job but also you have to do the
domestic labor you have to do the
emotional labor men to in today's
society like
yeah you have to get a job and you have
to like isn't that
sexist yeah but like yeah but yeah
but yeah i don't understand why it's
okay to be openly sexist against men but
it's not sad because what has been said
if women just behaved better that it
would be better because
that's that's the whole that's the whole
stream
i was only saying that to like combat
saying oh it's the women's fault what
about
we're not saying men could be a better
husband
and could help around the house more the
fact that men help around the house when
it's their house as well like that's
literally what it's called like there is
a like a disparity with the amount of
labor that women do and that men do yeah
make more money statistically so you
could just say the men contribute more
yeah men provide value like if a dude's
paying my rent he's not doing [ __ ] he's
not doing [ __ ] around the house
yeah but women also work so like they're
also doing a nine-to-five like maybe a
third so like what i'm saying
statistically men make more money i just
so go ahead i just wanted to ask all
your statistics and your percentages all
of that
where
did you find it is it in the uk is it in
the u.s and us
there's a little bit of a disparity yeah
between the uk and u.s specifically when
it comes to divorce is 64 in the uk and
it's 80 percent in the u.s who carried
out
um the government the government studies
how many women 100 women and then ask
them about their life and so do you
think do you think if you if you do
three four different studies and they
all come up to similar conclusions we
can we can say that it's around eighty
percent
yeah divorce lawyers
divorce court
we get in the statistics from there so
we can see who's initiating the divorces
like someone has to file right exactly
so when you fight for divorce it goes on
record so it's 80 of women that are
fighting for divorce
how would you improve the situation for
like
i feel like you both have like heard you
know thought about this a lot like what
would you say that both men and women
can do to improve the situation i think
a financial abortion should be legal
what do you mean what do you mean like i
think that if um women have the right to
get an abortion men should be able to
get a financial abortion so they can
sign off all rights and not pay any
child support whoa
[Music]
i would say that's one thing because the
way it is now like women are
incentivized to get kids off of rich
guys like the nba had to issue a
statement talent saying that women like
kept stealing condoms and i just think
that should be illegal like you
shouldn't be able to legally do drake
had to put hot sauce in his face yeah
like i'd say that's why stop this woman
from getting a baby there are women out
there literally incentivized to try and
get a rich man's baby that was just one
story with drake and one random lady and
it doesn't represent all women
so i understand that but i do these
interviews all the time so i'll go on
the street i'll talk to matt like i'll
talk to matt random people on the street
random people in my living room and i've
had so many guys tell me stories of
girls doing this to them go ahead and
you your guy's opinions favor a certain
side so when you go out on these
ventures and you ask people you know
what you're looking for you know what
you can put and edit
are you saying we're rigging
i would say i would say i get more
people that disagree to be honest when i
go out than agree so i wouldn't say i'm
like rigging the game okay but if you if
you're gonna have sex with a woman sorry
you can say so
can i say woman um
there isn't there is a chance that that
woman may get pregnant
like so if you have sex with a guy
there's a chance you might get pregnant
yeah yeah
yeah so so if you if you get to choose
not to be a mother you should get to
choose not to be a father
equal
equality
whose responsibility do you think it is
for getting pregnant
both of those
[Music]
so it's your responsibility if you get
pregnant even though it's it's it's no i
said who's responsibility for it to get
pregnant all of the power is within the
woman's hands you have the right to say
yes or no once you do say yes or no
you have the right to keep the baby you
have the right to either um put the baby
up for adoption you have the right to
put the man on child support we also we
also we also have birth control you can
get an iud it's like 99.99 percent
effective so yeah so these aren't great
though birth control isn't great to be
but i'm saying that's a better option
than what men have or you can require
them and you sleep with wear a condom so
it's like i'm saying we have all the
power when it comes to sex and who who
gives birth and who picks who is born
yeah nowadays a woman's i feel like a
woman is really only going to have a kid
if she like really wants to because
there's so many ways for her to prevent
that at different stages all throughout
but i also think if there were more
support for women who do want to have
children may not have necessarily found
the right man who actually wants to have
a child with her if she was able to get
more financial support then she wouldn't
feel like she'd need to trap a man oh
she's not going to get it that's that's
it that's a horrible excuse
are you excusing a girl trying to get a
kid off of a rich guy because she
doesn't want it i'm not trying to excuse
it but that's what you're doing if like
you know childcare is really expensive
okay
raising the child is really expensive
and it's really hard to do on your own
right yes
you should get married and do it
but what if no one wants to marry you
did you know that before you need to
you like want to marry you you're
probably shooting too high
change how you deal with it just like
just like if a dude's shooting at
victoria's secret models and they all
tell him no like he'll probably be like
i want me a joke what if you're like
just don't see any men that you like
sperm dollar yeah so if you're asexual
you don't have any romantic or sexual
interest ever you just want baby to live
life have a kid well isn't that selfish
to bring to bring a kid into a situation
it's it's not so you don't think
children need to to parents no well
i think they need a community because i
don't think they need two people one of
the reasons why society is broken
because women are actually literally
running around thinking that children
don't need two parents if you're a good
enough person you can teach a child
i just read you a bunch of stats showing
that
children that come from single mothers
are statistically a disadvantage in
nearly every category that's not
necessary and then you're going to tell
me oh yeah it's fine it's rated child's
body if you're like i don't i think i
think it's equally selfish if a dude
does the same thing
like if a dude if a dude wanted to i
don't know adopt as a single father like
i think that's selfish even if you can't
that doesn't necessarily mean you should
yeah like because you're putting you're
putting what you want about what is best
for the kids i think if you're adopting
a child whether you're a single person
or not i think that's a really lovely
thing to do because being in the care
system is not fun and if you're a single
parent it's better than having no parent
no one to look after you you've got care
workers in and out all day and also like
i lost my chain of dad but an ideal
situation would be an ideal situation is
two parents would you not agree with
that i would i would agree that you need
a support system it doesn't necessarily
mean it needs to be two parents you
could have four parents you could have
you could have cousins and aunties who
are older do you think it's the same as
having a mom and a dad in the home i've
never had both so i have no idea i could
not compare i think if the kid has
adults who love them and show that they
love them openly and always then it
doesn't matter if it's specifically a
man and a woman or two parents that
raise them if it's a community it's
someone that shows love so when all the
statistics that i read they never had a
father in the home there are so many
different hang on they never had a
father in the home okay it was single
they never had a father this shows that
boys and girls need both their mother
and their father to be
fully functioning members of society who
aren't going to be rapists who aren't
going to be
prisoners who aren't going to be you
know misfits but i i see this is one of
the things that i can't understand why
women would argue
for
single them and to raise a child by
themselves and then act like it's normal
like it's gonna it's gonna benefit
society it's gonna it's not gonna
benefit society when it comes to prison
it's not going to benefit society when
it comes to crime
so why do it i think what you've just
said is that you can't be a normal
functioning member of society if you're
raised
that's that that's that we're saying
that's what
okay but just because you heard it
that's not what he said that's not what
he said so what he what we're saying is
it puts you at every statistical
disadvantage so why would you push that
in a society i don't think
personally i'm not speaking to everyone
else i'm not pushing it but if that's
your best bet like
you know
then
that's all all you can do is your best
and if you're doing your best then like
what else can you get married
i think there's always there's
always there's always a guy that's going
to marry you like i'm sorry one out of
three men are either versions or haven't
had sex in the last year so the issue is
just like the guys that girls want don't
want them and so i think the the
solution is getting a guy on your level
i feel like the thing with the parents
the kids the mothers i feel like kids
are just kids they would they just
arrived here they don't know anything
the only way a kid is gonna be
disadvantaged from a single parent or
whatever is when they go grow up and
then they hear people talking about it
do you have a job as a kid you won't
notice who's raising you no i don't have
a chance i do
okay i've got something
and
i will tell you as a father i know from
raising my son that he needs both me and
his mother in his life so i so when
someone who hasn't had children is
telling me oh no kids don't need they're
both their parents i find it laughable
because because i tell you something
most parents will tell you that they
know
that their child needs both parents in
their life for you to say something like
that makes no sense to me as a parent it
doesn't make any sense i have kids in my
family that will raise single parents
and whatever or some kid kids in care
and stuff like that i feel like it's
laughable that you
just said oh my my life is this so
you're wrong
it's not it's not somebody said he's
saying my life
he's saying my life is this and stats
back it up
what about the statistics about what the
results are already into the because the
way you're going it's just like i
believe what i believe regardless of any
stats so you could see whatever stat and
you're still going to think what you
think yeah because i think so you can't
generalize anything in the world i don't
think anything can be generalized you
can't you have to generalize like unless
you're a therapist giving specific
advice like you have to do i think
people are too individual to even you
you're saying you can't generally you
can't say women are this you can't say
so and so is that you can't say children
prefer milk
you can't say
you can't say anything what do you mean
you can't generally
i never i don't say anything i don't say
women are this or dogs are that or
whatever it is i just say that thing
there is this and that's it and i don't
feel i don't i don't travel do dogs bark
some don't i don't know about that
so this is the thing that so now you
would just argue just to be right in in
a conversation because you know dogs
bark but for you to say oh some don't
it's like you know that that's what it
is then you can't argue anything
yeah because you get like if you don't
if you can't generalize at all then you
can't argue anything yeah
men and women and families i also think
there's a difference between ideal and
realism like the reality of people's
situation exactly i think a lot of women
would love to be married but they're
real realistically but they made poor
choices to not get there
maybe they did get married and maybe it
was a bad time
you know you never know the situation
but being a single mom is a lot of work
especially if you have like three kids
yeah so i'm saying like don't so don't
pick it
so don't pick it that's a choice yeah
you don't end up as a single mum by
accident like and you choose who you
sleep with
i don't know i think well maybe if that
husband was better she wouldn't have
left
always
why is that okay but
maybe if she was maybe maybe if she
maybe if she was better she wouldn't
have left i think if they both worked on
it then yeah i think we can both agree
people should work on their
relationships before calling it quits
but there's you know there's reality
there's a reality and ideal
i think women should get should should
be more discerning when deciding which
mandate okay but women have only
recently earned like over the last like
20 30 years right which isn't a long
time period in the grand scheme it's
being especially generational
it's two generations fair enough two
generations
will still be there yeah yeah it's too
generous what does that have to do with
me today
no no i'm a woman what does that have to
do with me today woman had to rely on
men for like you said financial support
to be able to work to be able to live
essentially and as we've come out of
that yes it's been what like 40 50 years
right as we've come probably a bit
longer no about 50 60 years to say that
and and
they had to rely on settling to be able
to get a man to be able to support them
so we are still shifting out of that
mindset where you you settle for
something that maybe isn't that great
because you have to be supported you
have to have this nuclear family
situation i grew up with two parents in
the house i grew up with a relative you
know two parents who were incredibly
functioning society but i was suicidal
by the time i was 12. so it doesn't
having two parents doesn't blanketly
assume that you're going to be happy
like those statistics that you read off
it's not necessarily because the kid had
a single matter there are so many
different systemic issues that go into
that poverty you know where you live
like different aspects it's not just
about having a single mother i've got a
question for you all the girls on the
panel um so
i learned this a couple weeks ago that
women are very picky when it comes to
men
my question is
if you were given the choice
would you marry a guy you're not
attracted to knowing that he's going to
stay
in the relationship and paul feel free
to rephrase my question if you feel i'm
saying it wrong or
so would you marry a guy that you're not
attracted to but you know he's going to
stay there he's going to provide and
everything or would you marry the guy
that's cheated
multiple times but you are madly in love
with him who would you be with that's a
boundary
i'll go first
personally i would say neither and
because i've been in both of those
situations where i've had someone who
would be a perfect option but i wasn't
attracted to them and i've had someone
that i've been madly in love with who
[ __ ] around with me essentially i've
been in both those situations and i
think the issue is people have to think
they have to settle for those situations
so
which one neither neither
sorry i don't know it's a cop out but i
wouldn't choose either i'm not doing i
wouldn't i would rather be on my own all
right if those are my choices if you
could give me one if
life on the line one
i would choose the one i'm not attracted
to cool
me too okay yep
i think i also have to say neither i'm
not somebody who's ever necessarily if
your life is on the line
if your life is on the line pick one i'd
rather die
i think
honestly like the way you guys are
answering like that's why 50 of women
over 30 are single and childless right
yeah because they want to be it's a
decision
it's not necessarily because they're
also the least happy group when they hit
like 45 or 50. correct because like the
party runs out
someday like someday no one's lining up
to date you at a certain age yep and
it's not really a decision because the
guys are the ones who control who gets
relationships i mean from what i can see
it seems like the crux is you need to
understand that just because you don't
like your options doesn't mean you
should gaslight yourself but you're
believing you don't have any you know
like yeah and your options are just
that's your level so like if you if you
don't like the guys you can date then
like you should probably try to improve
yourself well yeah and i definitely
agree with that i believe you should
work onto yourself until you're ready to
be in a relationship that you want and
that's why i would rather be alone until
i'm ready for a relationship that's
going to be reciprocal in all ways and i
think that's the mindset it shouldn't be
about whether people are going to settle
for a relationship or anything like this
people should be open to working on
themselves be open to like not being
judgmental do you think it's about love
do you think at a certain age though
it's kind of just like okay like like
let's say 32 you you only really have
till 35 if you want to have kids and you
don't have because geriatric pregnancy
is like 20 000 a year so the average
person can't afford that if you want a
family and you want kids do you think
there's a certain age where you kind of
look around and be like you know what i
don't think my options are going to get
better than this because i'm just
getting older
i think yes and no
because i a lot of times like when we
say settle
like maybe he's settling for her like
how can we just say women are settling
when that's your level i think that's
like saying a guy saying oh i didn't get
a victoria's secret model so i settled
yeah
i think i think i think settling
okay but that's i think settling for
appearance is different in terms of
settling for the way someone behaves so
the way someone treats you if you're
settling for someone who doesn't treat
you the way you deserve to be treated
who isn't present who doesn't show up or
treats you the way you want to be
treated then
you're settling for yourself and i think
every i think the idea is that we have
limited options which we don't so
attracted to different things yeah so if
women if women hate um men that don't
treat them right right then why do we
all seem to date them correct
trauma generational trauma
a whole bunch of stuff
so many different things it's not an
excuse it's genuinely what's going on
women are attracted to bad boys
at a certain age
women are attracted to bad boys so women
see red flags in men um they see a
certain type of man generally i'm not
we know it's not all women yeah and they
still go for that type of man do you
know about attachment theory by any
chance how we pursue relationships that
remind us of our earliest anxious
anxious attached like that sort of thing
right so especially in terms of like
anxious attachment and that sort of
thing you tend to seek relationships
where even if someone's treating you
negatively you think you're the problem
so you do anything you can to change
yourself to match that behavior and
that's why women stay in relationships
because they have this self-deprecating
view of themselves
insecurity i wouldn't say broken i don't
like the word broken well because that's
what this is about
unhealed i would say
no but i would make that point i don't
think society is broken i don't i think
unhealed and broken are very different
things i think
but you don't you don't think if you
keep them you don't think if you keep
dating bad partner after bad partner
like maybe it's you maybe do you know
maybe the trauma goes for someone to
constantly put themselves in that
situation where they constantly make the
wrong choice so
deep and that can be so subconscious
it's so difficult to consciously bring
to mind if you don't have the right
people to talk to you about it
or you could just make better like yeah
like an excuse
even if it is an excuse it's a genuine
excuse that people deal with not really
at the end of the day
i have an anxious i have an anxious
attachment style but i'm not i'm not
going to blame that on my poor choices
like i'm just going to i'm just going to
say that was a poor choice and i'm going
to learn from it i'm not going to say oh
that's your childhood but yeah like no i
mean i could i could i could do a whole
sob story behind ten siblings
you can acknowledge the poor choice and
still like see that you can make better
some people just can't see that or you
could just say oh this is a poor choice
i this is on me this is my fault i'm
gonna move on some people don't have the
ability to be able to everyone everyone
has the ability to you make that a
choice it's not it's not something so
deeply i don't i'm going to say yes but
i don't like the word broken i say
unhealthy i also think when you get to
broken women broken society but it's not
just broken woman it's broken men it's
broken people no but it's not just
broken woman okay so you're talking
about anxious anxious attacks attachment
styles yeah we're talking about uh women
who choose men right when women choose
men
men women have babies by these men right
so like well generally women are having
babies right so if they're choosing
these men having babies by these men
what are these children going to be
that's what i said what are these
children going to be like because the
next generation that is going to be
raising the society the next generation
that matters in the society
is the children okay and so like i said
if the women aren't if the women are
broken
you are going to raise a broken society
men are involved in that too yeah
hang on but you were telling me that
it's okay to raise a child without a man
yeah so you're saying old men are
involved but you don't want the man
involved no i'm not saying that's a
blessing so then what we do in here
what we doing are we i'll be raising
nuclear families or i'll be are we doing
the whole single mother thing
are we being broken we raising broken
children what are we doing i don't
understand how women are broken because
they choose bad men so that means broken
society but women batman they're bad men
they're just being chosen the bad men
are there that's the subject bad men are
broken but the majority of men
are good men
it's a very it's a very no it's a very
small percentage of men that are
sleeping with all the women like it's a
very like if you want a guy that's over
six foot that's 15 of men you want to be
cute cut that in half you want to make
money cut that in half it's a very small
percentage of men that are sleeping with
all the girls
like every girl has a guy in their
friend zone that would treat them well
and they know would treat them well and
they know likes them
and it's like we don't pick them
and then we're going to cry because the
guy we picked is bad to us you could
have picked the guy in the friend zone i
feel like it's just like a
like a fairy tale like i don't think
this actually exists in the world i
think it's like a high school musical
like movie plot i don't think it's
actually wait so this is wait you've
never friends owned a guy
no
i've never friend zoned him if a guy
asked me out you even say yes or no i'm
not going to stay friends with him
because i just i just pied him off
that's so awkward
so i mean i'm not going to do that
you've never had a guy that you would
say is a nice guy ask you out yeah okay
so then why don't you date him i've had
a nice guy ask oh yeah so i'm saying
yeah but that's what i'm saying like
like
we complain about men but we pick who we
date but i've met nice guys who i'm into
just because i didn't settle for the guy
that i wasn't just into is nice i met
someone else who was into that i was
nice and we didn't know what i'm saying
i'm saying like the guys that treat you
like [ __ ] usually treat you like [ __ ]
because they have a bunch of options
they don't care but i also think your
your china blanket statement and say
like all women like bad guys like i've
never once been like he's been really
mean to me let me let me go near him
more like i am very lucky that both of
my exes were really like stand up lovely
lovely men and like not every woman i
think
you perpetuate that women like bad guys
men are going to treat women like it's
not like something is being perpetuated
it's like the actions that we can
actually see you know you can either you
can either judge
based off what you hear people say or
how they actually move and how they
actually act well i only know how i act
and i i do and that's why we're
generalizing but there's always certain
people who do have negative
relationships with men and i do agree
that there are attachment styles but i
also agree that you get to a certain age
and it's your responsibility to sort
your own [ __ ] out before you get into it
sometimes it can be difficult you said
that your exes were nice guys yeah then
why are you not with them or why are you
not with them the first one
he was a bit older than me i was at uni
and he said look i'm waiting for you to
graduate for you to come back um to make
a family make a baby do you want that
and i said
i wanted to move to london and he was
like i've never moved to london so he
broke up
and the other one
it's a bit techy but i loved him but our
communication just wasn't
communicating and it was it was like in
lockdown and it was like
both of us it wasn't just him it wasn't
just me we were both like really like
it was very like
just it was nothing too much but it was
just not a nice environment no i'm
saying did you leave him or did he leave
you the first one he left me no the
second one second one i left him and i
still love him but yeah but the first
one you could have chose to be with if
if you wanted to right if you wanted to
start a family and then yeah and so like
the way men look at it is like basically
you had two options of like nice guys
you could have married and then later if
you come back and complain that you have
no one which i'm not saying you're gonna
do that but i'm saying a common
complaint is a lot of women do that and
they're like well you didn't want us
when you were young
it wasn't necessarily that i didn't want
them like i love them both yeah dearly
and if they were both in london i
probably would date one but the thing is
is that like life just takes you
different ways and i want the best for
them and i don't even know if i think
people make choices and then i mean
that's consequences it's not like life
takes you different ways you make
choices right and then the consequences
to your actions
yeah that's fair enough there's nothing
wrong with that but you just need to
understand that actions have
consequences and you know you might like
the action but
you might not like the consequence you
know and that doesn't mean you should
blame you know life went different ways
no you had you took an action and
there's a consequence now that you don't
like even though you like the action
initially i think the way in which when
it comes when it comes to breakups what
i hear a lot is that um women
women's stories or breakups versus men's
stories or breakups always always like
they always amuse me because women
always have this convoluted way of way
they feel and how it went down and it's
never just someone said they didn't want
to be in a relationship generally
because someone initiates that first
conversation someone says is it working
out or
are we doing well
and then the conversation ensues and
then you kind of decide so someone
generally
makes that first move but when you come
to women it's like it's as if we can't
really get to the bottom of who broke up
with you and when we do is you broke up
with him but you're telling me that he's
a nice guy and if he's a nice guy and he
should be with him exactly like it
doesn't make any sense like if he's a
nice guy you should be with the guy
why are you not with the nice guy
exactly i mean like
with me and my ex it was quite clear
like why we broke up like she was like
okay we're either gonna start living
together or that's it and i was like
okay cool you know that's it because i
value living on my own and she wanted
that but i was just like no so it's
quite clear you know but i know what you
mean when women tend to talk about
breakups it's like and this isn't
awesome
it's just like the word salad
it's like it's nothing specific it's
just all these vague intelligences
you can just be real like
it's cool as men you have to understand
that our brains work differently because
we understand if you if you spoke to a
guy and he said oh you're not with your
girl yeah i'm not with my girl oh what
happened yeah this is what happened bro
this happened that happened that
happened this happened and we're gone
right so you get the story but when this
woman was like yeah well what happened
is the communication weren't
communicating
what are you talking about you know what
i mean it's like come on
it doesn't make any sense to us as men
anyway doesn't make any sense i'm going
to take a second to read super chats um
there are a lot in the chat is like
begging me to read them
there are oh my gosh um
guys i am gonna try to get through all
of these
i'm sorry i might have to skip one or
two i'm sorry i'm sorry okay
um stefan pierre jerome when you're
asking the group questions you need some
type of individual answer abroad to
avoid group answers and choices das
token broken women can't create create
strong able children just like poor
parents can't teach children how to
become rich they don't even know what it
looks like jason bennett's sexual
liberation has not been healthy for
society sentience the audacity of a
guest to come onto a podcast and attempt
to language police one of the hosts by
using that masculine karen ask demand to
use unhealed if the roles were reversed
you would decry oppression the forest
there has to be a lack of correlation
between chest there has to be a
correlation between chest tattoos and
lack of accountability
matt butcher hey sarah hey sarah
can you can you fill mine it's like hot
in here okay thank you thank you um
matt butcher to the ladies um
to the ladies sincere thanks for coming
on the show to teach men what to avoid
and how a woman should not be flora and
it's everyone's fault but yours
basically allison alistair alistair
horton who winds up more broke the women
emotionally or the men financially billy
boy ladies be like i deserve a man that
i deserve also real also girl it's
unrealistic for men to expect an
in-shaped spouse the double standards
never stop mj talks if you don't stand
for something then you stand for nothing
we have allowed women the individualist
theory where everyone is special and the
undeserving of judgment men stop dealing
with women like this brett cormier thank
you
i hope the women come to understand that
you will fall in and out of love with
your partner over the years my parents
have been married 50 plus years and they
have not always been in love with each
other but they know they were better
together than apart
m t jeebs imagine a whole lifetime
thinking that the right stars will align
you and you will find everything perfect
without changing anything or challenging
yourself sentience hey zed waiting for
that
hey red rating for that reciprocal
relationship is bad advice for women
because you what you may look for in a
man you well you may look for x in a man
that man isn't looking for the same in
you but you should definitely wait alone
with your cats um think and repent um
pearl thank you pearl thank you so much
i'm super chatting for the men who
couldn't because they are dead suicide
is off the charts for young men chris
thank you for the ladies on the panel i
would not be able to keep
this is funny thank you to the ladies on
the panel i would not be able to keep my
stable of side chicks if it wasn't for
women like you co-signing the lies that
i tell them you are helping us high net
worth men pump and dump these delusional
girls you are my virtual wing woman
basics of pain generally i enjoy the
show but the women are so delusional i
just can't with the women starting from
an unreasonable position combined with
the inability to accept stats and facts
just wow
i am hollow we can generalize for
example all the women here spew the same
old drivel and bs that all modern women
believe it's too predictable at this
point missandri and a need to be right
isn't a good combo
cinders kindly ask the three women on
the couch if they have good
relationships with their fathers the
savvy ninja in the 1800s the women would
walk down the street accidentally drop a
handkerchief while walking by the guy
they fancies the guy would pick it up
and go in on her and say hi they chose
zachary payne women that are pearl
they're not excluding the facts they
would rather hold on outdated hippie
ideology ladies you have been lied to
jordan peterson exposed the exposed
though and why mgtow biologic women
don't settle settling means content with
the less with less than you wanted women
don't do this
women don't do women don't do this women
take less temporarily than withhold sex
cheat until they're divorced then go
find a new sucker
um
sentience you can't generalize you mean
like how you say women are sexually
repressed or men are trashed how
disingenuous of you to only pick
exceptions to the rule when it suits
your argument but gleefully use the same
generalizations to shift blame matt
butcher the mentality of these ladies is
total justification for abolish
abolishing welfare
brit cormier 99 is not great for birth
control lolol pearl can how can you
breathe with all the copium booms fumes
i don't know what copium is in this room
uh
oh
my bad okay um
lawrence bullock the
biggest problem with modern women is
they all have they all they have all the
rights and no accountability will will
william nusen so when does the baby
become ours and when does it
so when does the baby become ours and
when does it become hers only and switch
back to ours sentience do you not
do you not think if men behaved better
women would stay says the woman say says
the woman who said that it was the
woman's fault when sarah garvey read
pure statistics hello pot you have met
the kettle check that privilege zenti
it's a hundred dollar super chat
let's go um you sentience you can't put
that stat on the mother but you can
because she chose poorly the man she
laid down with if she didn't know he was
a bad nan
if she didn't know he was a bad man why
not wait can't wait to vet him why keep
the baby if women are more mature than
men why do you dodge account ability
um phillip smith women aren't
biologically attracted to big buff
wealthy dudes that's socially consistent
women aren't biologically attracted to
big buff wealthy dudes that's socially
conditioned do you see how dumb that
sounds
um oh my gosh guys there's so many i'm
gonna skip to the bigger ones i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry there's so many um
sentients reclaiming the sexual power
through liberation what utter utter
rubbish this generation encourages each
other to be more outrageous for clout
and more deviant in the name of
liberation and empowerment and they're
layman there and lament their choices
around 30 because you're a 304
zentians i've watched two or more and
not signed up i would like pearl to read
chats properly and allow for reactions
from the channel
they want you to read the move okay
ah they always come they always
they always complain i'm sorry sentience
i'll try to do better i'll try to do
better um um gennar lanters have her
define
oh god i can't read this dahimi and
jizzy huh
oh shoot this is from a different video
okay now i got through i was like what
are you talking about okay okay um
um yeah we're gonna we're gonna um as a
matter of fact do any of the ladies want
to respond to it oh yeah yeah do you
have any yeah go ahead
it's silly
before we get into the next video that
we're gonna watch um
because you seem to be upset at a lot of
the comments i'm just saying you might
want to respond i don't know i just
thought they were silly and stupid and
dumb and ridiculous in terms of me
policing language here it's just a word
that i prefers to use i understand that
people prefer to use broken that's fine
but for me i'd rather refer to it as
unhealed people can say what they want
i'm not policing anyone that's all i'm
going to say okay um
we've got another video uh to see um
this one should be interesting i want to
get you guys view
on this one uh pearl of you queue yeah
yeah i haven't pulled up uh is she
queued it up on there let me see the
time stamps again it's from the
beginning to like 139. yeah i got you
okay
it should let me know when you've
let me turn um
sound back on my laptop
just want to get people's view on
what they see here
hi
hi what's your name
hello
hi
hi what's your name shania shania where
are you calling us from columbus ohio
columbus ohio's in the building
shania um columbus how old are you
i am 30.
30 years old do you have any children i
have two and i also have custody of my
niece
okay so three kids live with you yep
okay hello to your kids
um thirteen three and then my niece is
nine
thirteen three and nine thirteen your
your children do they have the same dad
no
was you ever married
no
why are you not with the three-year-old
dad
so we have the same birthday and we
can't ask i hope it's not my wi-fi
i think no girl i apologize i think it's
mine okay all right so let's try it
again so why are you not with a
three-year-old dad
um i'll be totally honest and
transparent so my youngest daughter is a
one-night stand baby
we co-parent well
we just didn't take it anywhere after
after the one-night stand
um yeah like y'all don't wear condoms in
one night stands
i mean i can explain to you the story if
you wanna i wanna hear it
okay so i was in a relationship with a
guy for seven years that was my longest
relationship
um we broke up and i
let loose and yeah i definitely should
have
used protection but it was my birthday
it was his birthday we was drunk
and yeah we made a baby
yeah that's hilarious yeah what do we
think of um
that broken women
broken society oh wait also one thing
one quick thing guys we're turning the
chat on to members only so become a
member if you want to be a part of the
chat anyways go ahead
um
these women like this one night stand
babies because it's her birthday are
raising the next generation
and and i'm sure
women like that are not an isolated case
there are many
women like that specifically in america
um
where there are children being raised
by women who are so frivolous
with
their vaginas let's say right that they
give it to any and everyone and now
they've got children to race because of
it what do we figure it out
what about the what about willy though
that was frivolous
willie's too
yeah but but like i said
women decide who they have children with
we spoke about that already it's the
women that are deciding to have these
children
because it's a bigger risk for them it's
a big role whenever it's a bigger risk
for you you have to exercise more risk
management because you're the one who
could end up in a much more negative
situation
and we have and we have more options
when it comes to preventing that sort of
stuff than men do yeah
definitely i feel like that
the story i feel like the story of that
was
probably not representing a large number
of
and remember that her child is not
represented in a large number of
children remember the video before right
yeah
and then you see this one yeah that's
two videos two videos but how i'm saying
if you go on kendrick show
no it's
i try to get on kendra they never let me
on yeah i feel like
i feel like i would kill that show
but but no um no they literally are
always like that like
people that call into that show oh okay
i say so it's uh
i don't i don't i don't think it's the
majority of women but i think there's a
large minority yeah that like a
substantial minority of women that are
delusional yeah i mean there's a large
minor there's a large amount of just
general delusional people i just feel
like this is not
that video in that video and that tv
show that is specifically for those
videos no that's just videos that you've
seen and i don't think it represents the
pizza so here's the thing right
because i don't i don't see men calling
into shows and demanding victoria's
secret models like i just don't see it i
see women demanding six figure guys tall
guys whatever but i don't see girls
or guys calling into shows and saying i
need a model yeah you just get laughed
at he'll he just was like yeah she's
okay not fat wait that's enough no kids
what a question so someone's calling
into that show for a man
yeah it's it's like a match
yeah yeah go ahead go ahead
okay so turn on your camera come on come
on
[Applause]
uh oh
yeah give it a sec
i'll i'll add it on okay then okay this
is
all right we'll watch the second part of
it and then i'll add my point okay let's
watch the second part cool um from 10 15
10 15.
yeah from 10 15.
i just
[Laughter]
yeah i want to get your guys views on
this where is it 10
okay 10 15. yeah
let's have a look because you said was
she calling that shoulders for a man
we saw a guy who's that in the
background
who's that in the background speak you
could talk you've been talking to me all
the time i told you or what
that's the guy you had sex with today
so you so the guy you had sex with today
is in your house and you're on my show
looking for a new guy
i'm on my i'm on your show to tell you
that i'm single and if you know i find
it on my show to look for a new guy
because that's what this show is about
so
i'm on the show just to put myself out
there yes yeah you're on this you're on
the show to meet a new guy that's what
the show is about let's be clear okay
we're not going to circle around the
fact of the show right you come on the
show to meet whomever if you're into
women you're intimate so
you want to meet a guy
while you have the guy you slept with
in your house
what kind of quality man you think is
gonna hit you up
i'm just being honest i mean
i mean i'm being honest too what kind of
quality man you think is gonna hit you
up yeah i don't know you tell me kendra
not one okay
a me and i might have that a man will
hit you up that want to have sex with
you but not a man that's gonna take you
serious
not absolutely not there is no man
that's watching this right now a quality
man that's gonna hit you up and take you
serious with the guy you slept with this
morning in the background while you on
this show and if that's what you desired
and that's what you desire it's your
life but you're gonna have to own up to
the fact that you got a lot of stuff to
get together very trifling if you want
us and if you wanna if you wanna attract
the trifling guy they're so big give
them your instagram page or your
facebook page
so i just
on yeah i think that's hilarious i just
hope she has that same kind of comedic
energy if you know or let's say when she
ends up like being really alone um and a
lot older with like you know boxed wine
and cats you know
but what but for me
i need to understand the psychology
i need to understand the psychology
that makes you think that you can call a
dating show
yeah with the with the person that
you've just had sex with in your house
looking for another person because i've
i'll say this
i don't think a man would do that
i don't think a man would call a dating
show
with the woman walking around naked in
the background that you just had sex
with saying yeah i'm saying i'm saying i
want to get another girl i don't think
men would do that i think they would do
that for their lads
they'd go be like yeah i've got a girl
but i'm you know yeah
she wouldn't go in the day but like men
really going like welcome dating shows
because the thing is going on a dating
show doesn't always mean you want to go
on a date a lot of the time you just
want attention
so do you think she's actually looking
for a man i don't think she was i kind
of got the feeling she was just trying
to go viral and then she was like
just to see what's out there you know i
would actually i would actually magnify
that to a on a bigger scale i don't
think a lot of girls actually want to
date i think they just want attention as
well you know and i'm not saying there's
anything wrong with that i'm just saying
it is what it is you know like if you
want to if you just want attention
that's fine but if you're going to
masquerade that as like you want to date
and find a nice guy then
you do you think that's a bit selfish
when you have kids to do that
like how embarrassing would that be if
that if you're in school and your mom's
calling into a dating show with some
dude in the background
no that's pretty awesome yeah pretty
awful and this woman's i said she said
she's got two children
and so yeah sorry no go ahead guys she
got two children the last one was for a
guy that she had a one night stand with
because it was her birthday
and the guy's walking around in the
background and i'm just saying like i
said if i'll go back to it if women like
this are raising the next generation we
are going to be raising a society of
broken people
so what do you suggest you do about a
woman like people like that how would
you how would you
you know i think women need i think
personally feminism women's liberation
has been a detriment to society
i really do believe well there's so many
different types of feminism well i with
this this aggressive type the first wave
feminism i don't have a problem with as
a matter of fact um this aggressive type
feminism radical a radical i don't need
no man men are trash
um
i don't know
i can do it all by myself
okay type feminism for me leads to women
like this thinking that they can call up
a show just have sex with a man because
she's an independent woman right she's
saying she's single she's just had a
penis inside her this morning right and
she's saying that she's single and she's
on the show but the thing is there's no
shame
yeah i think there's psychology there's
no shame you can do whatever you want
and there will be absolutely no
ramifications but that's not how life
works right yeah anyway i mean it would
be great if that were the case i think
we would all love that but that's just
not how reality works don't you think in
a similar way that's what men have been
doing for the yeah the problem is that
you
know
how so
wait can i could i hear it could i just
hear how in terms of what have been been
doing for a long time okay as in kind of
um not been doing what they've been
allowed to do and they've been in cut
maybe you might be encouraged they might
be promoted so or just they had a safe
space to do it to kind of do what like
do whatever they want in that sense like
if we talk about like what we mentioned
earlier like side chicks that sort of
thing it's kind of like an accepted
thing where they have a lot less
parameters around what they're allowed
to do sexually so maybe a man's not
calling into like a dating show but he's
definitely like you know having sex with
a woman and looking for the next one
so the majority
the majority of men historically haven't
been doing that because most men don't
even reproduce
really yeah like most men throughout
history didn't reproduce eight thousand
so is it eight thousand is about the
kids that you're more focused on lessons
eight thousand eight thousand years ago
it was 17 women to one man that
reproduce so it's more about the kids
so no so women
women would pick the guy historically so
they could have picked a guy with worse
jeans but like women biologically you
want to get the best genes you can to
pass under your kid
so so going back to what you said yeah
you said men have been doing it the
problem with the society and the problem
with the feminist movement is that women
think they can do the same things that
men can do and they can't they cannot do
the same things that men can do they
think they can and they think they're
good the consequences and the
ramifications are going to be the same
they're not going to be the same and so
women use this argument all the time oh
well if men can do it we can no
okay do it and then see what happens
do it and we see what happens if you've
got a child
you know from one nightstand baby
because it was your birthday that child
has now got to grow up with a mom who's
basically a whole
right do you know what i mean it's just
like
women of this generation need to
understand and i'm not saying
i think this whole feminist movement has
made women think that they can become
the worst type of men that have ever
existed in history so there have been
really bad men in history right and men
have done really bad things this
movement has made women think oh i can
do what those bad men can do
those men are they're [ __ ] up do you
know what i mean like those are bad guys
you don't need to be like the bad guy
but and they also don't appreciate the
good men i mean right i mean you realize
the majority of women didn't even want
to but want the right to vote because it
came with the you had to be drafted
so most if you polled women from back
then they said that i don't want that
and that's the thing women have been
protected throughout all of history i
also don't think everyone agrees with
radical feminism like that it's a very
like niche feminism and like generally
to say
the general feminism is about choice and
that you have choice to do things that
always comes with a consequence but for
me
radical is not my vibe
to me to me there's there's only one
wave of feminism like i disagree
feminism has always been about freedom
without the responsibility starting with
the right to vote it was the freedom of
voting without the responsibility of
getting drafted
i feel like you had something to say go
ahead no i'm just listening at the
moment
and eventually maybe
i don't think that was necessarily like
the root of first wave feminism though i
think that like
speaking through the mic yep sorry it
was started i'm sorry sorry yeah
so yeah i think that like
you know like historically when we talk
about this concept of feminism we are
looking at it in western culture first
wave being attached to that like right
to vote but i think historically also
when we look at like
majority people of color people from
like lower more like impoverished
classes
we have these ideals around like women
who need to like
be working people who women who need to
be providing all of this other
um support systems for their community
which i think is also feminism and was
also always there even within those like
first waves can i can i just read you
something that you you might not have
known so um
feminism was started in 1848 in seneca
falls in new york the suffrages had 200
men and 100 women
in the 1800s to the 1920s they were seen
as terrorists planning assassination it
was seen as a supremacism movement i did
know that yeah okay okay yeah
so you don't you don't think even then
it it would have been oh yeah it was
totally extremist son okay yeah so what
what are you talking about this extreme
is now
so that's what i thought you were
talking about when you're saying the
first wave of feminism yeah well because
i feel like i guess just in like
theoretical discourse you have like
three waves and like into a fourth wave
which hasn't quite finished yet which is
what like i guess we're kind of talking
about now like the radical like fourth
wave that isn't done yet right we're
trying to like
figure out what that might be
um but i think like whatever that
radical fourth wave might be
also isn't what
the majority of women um are even like
feeling or practicing in their everyday
lives i also think that like
i think it kind of has gone the other
way a little bit in the fact that like
if you want to be a housewife it's
looked down upon i think like the value
because like we live in a capitalist
society um
you are valued by how much money you
make therefore i from i don't know if
this is true it's my opinion it's my
theory like
in the olden days suffragettes were
usually like middle class women with
money they didn't have any
responsibilities like for example they
didn't have any value as in their money
weren't wasn't theirs and they probably
wanted ownership for it if you're
working class if you were like bottom of
the barrel like you were working anyway
you had to make money right so
suffragette was not for people with jobs
already is for women who already wanted
money because they wanted to be valued
in society they weren't valued the same
as their husband for example
now
i think
today
it's not valued financially right
it's never been valued financially to be
a mother especially now but then you get
married like there's a lot of child
support now like you have to have a job
and be a mother being a mother is a
full-time job and you never sleep and i
think like if women were valued in the
feminine like typical female roles then
maybe like life would be better because
i would love to be a housewife
it's just it feels like it's not even a
it's not even an option anymore
economically like with the first guy
could you have been um
no not no because like we'd like i don't
know i don't know how much money he's
like because project engineer whatever
but like i wouldn't have been able to be
just a whole like a housewife like
economically that's just not viable
anymore unless you're dating like
millionaires billionaires well you know
what's crazy my friends i have a really
good friend that's a housewife and she
she went like she was trending on
twitter for just saying that she was a
housewife and she served her she loves
her husband she serves him he's the boss
and like it's crazy to me that that so
much backlash foreign
because mothers are so important
um so important well that's why it goes
back to statistics about a nuclear
family
right that i read in the beginning of
the show because having that nuclear
family is essential for societies to
function um i i think the society is a
little bit dis well a lot dysfunctional
because of the lack of nuclear family
structure yeah and you know i would also
argue that it is possible
as a woman i guess to find a guy who's
able to look after you and your kids so
you don't have to work but the reality
is you need to be strategic about how
you're going to actually get that guy to
commit to you you need to provide value
in certain ways and a lot of women like
and i'm not saying this is good or bad
it's just they need to understand what
the consequences of this belief is going
to be right you need to understand if
you believe that a guy who has a lot of
options should just choose you why
because you're you then the result of
that is not going to be you know
amicable for you right that's the
reality so you need to realize that or
women need to realize that if you're
going to keep a guy who has a lot of
options you need to provide a lot of
tangible value apart from just whatever
you can do in
a sexual domain well but also
also um in reverse to that
um if a man wants a woman of a caliber
or a certain caliber he has to provide
100 so many different things as in like
wealth he has to be
the type of man she would admire look up
to in any way shape or form he has to
behave in a certain manner for her to
even like somewhat respect him or feel
comfortable
just essentially
relinquishing
certain powers of course i mean
yeah well everything a woman does in a
relationship is for her happiness
everything a mandan is does in a
relationship is for a woman's happiness
generally
a woman does things in a relationship so
she can be happy
right and then the man
does things in a relationship so she can
be happy
right happy wife happy life right so we
get that term happy wife happy life and
so what happens is all of this attention
is just thrown upon the woman it's all
about her happiness all about her
happiness all about you keep an open
happy and a man goes out generally he
goes out to work brings home the bacon
yeah and he's got to protect this whole
structure he's got to protect her
happiness
make sure she's happy and then keep her
happy all the while negate in his own
generally he negates his own happiness
to keep the woman happy do you get what
i'm saying wouldn't you
agree then that the issue is more that
we should fulfill our own happiness
instead of relying on our partners to
fulfill that for us and that will shift
the dynamic of being like having that
dependence and so if a woman has that
independent energy she's able to look
after herself she's able to attract a
man who can look after himself and
together they can probably look after a
child because they're not searching for
their happiness in each other so
wouldn't you say that's more the issue i
think yeah i think people should
fulfill themselves within whatever
happiness whatever makes them happy yeah
i don't think life's about happiness
it's about fulfillment and i think and i
think women over a certain age are not
fulfilled because if they don't have a
husband and a family like what are you
going to do at 60 by yourself you have a
job you have a job that could fire you
tomorrow do you think that's because
we've been taught that that's what
fulfills us especially in terms of that
nuclear family no no no no
so to answer your question to answer
your question no i think it's biology i
think you can't undo biology but i think
even biology to an extent is taught
because it's evolved it's evolved from
what we practice over and over and over
again right so that's still generational
to me that's still taught that goes back
that dynamic goes back years but it
doesn't mean necessarily that it's the
most healthy dynamic yeah that goes back
hundreds of years
thousands of years you know social
constructs change every what a couple
hundred years biology is like well
scientists estimate three hundred
thousand years that human beings have
been like three hundred thousand years
of evolutionary biology that's not
really a that's a very formidable
opponent that you don't really want to
be going because it's less like in the
past than that i mean the roles the
roles of kind of like more in like
sophisticated society we live in this
society where that role is a bit more
structured it's a bit more defined than
it was previously where the woman was um
the nurturer of the forager you know she
had an active role in society she was
just as important as the man she was
seen as an equal because they had equal
roles instead of the man being this
power when sorry sorry
when um
i couldn't give you a specific tactic
because i think before like
sophisticated societies start developing
even like medieval stages
i don't think it was ever equal because
men always had to protect women but that
doesn't mean that the woman's um
position is less valued it's valued it's
it's valuable in a different i'm saying
they did different things exactly but
i'm just i
like no one's talking about what's more
valuable or what's less but both are
valuable yeah yeah yeah they're both
yeah nobody's saying women like what
they do isn't valuable what we're saying
is men and women are different and you
can't you can't undo biology and i don't
know why you would want to change
something that's worked for thousands
and thousands of years so it's like
don't you think it's a bit arrogant to
come in and don't you think it's a bit
arrogant to come in and say you know
better than like thousands of years of
people i think it's more the rigidity
i'm talking about the rigidity of the
roles that we are expected to be in a
certain way
so to me like i i've always been told i
can do anything and i could be like i
could start a business i could do what i
want i've never been pushed into roles
and if anything i've seen more backlash
for women that go into traditional roles
than women that act more modern
so i i don't think society's really
pushing women to be traditional anymore
i know and that's i definitely agree
with that because it is pushing women to
be more professional because
in capitalism where your value comes
from
not by everyone but
people see you
in a higher status if you earn more
money you earn no money looking after
children unless you're a nanny and when
you look at the salary of inani compared
to a banker you know
it's not it's and that's why women feel
like they need to go off and like
succeed and become a valuable member of
society because they don't feel like
having a baby is enough to be valued
which is so depressing but why does it
shouldn't it shouldn't shouldn't it only
matter if your husband values you who
cares what society thinks
everyone that's like humans care what
other humans think like that's like how
to stay in in a society to not get
kicked out of one to die or you're right
you actually care what other people
think and you want to make sure that
everything yeah but you need to pick the
people whose opinions you actually value
right you can't just value everyone's
opinions because at the end of the day
people
people's lives their lifestyle is a
reflection of the opinions that they
have so if you don't want this person's
lifestyle in future then you really
shouldn't be internalizing their
opinions because you will be doing
yourself a massive decision very
difficult there's a certain level of
consciousness that requires that as well
which is like an incredibly privileged
space to be in because if you are living
in survival mode effectively which a lot
of people are then you don't have the
conscious awareness to make those
decisions you're going to keep falling
into those survival patterns because you
can't physically step out of that you
don't have the choice to and because of
different systemic pressures so many
different factors contributing to that
i just have no idea what you just said i
would argue from personally i don't know
i mean i would argue from personal
experience that's incorrect like when i
left home when i was 17 and it was all
about survival i really couldn't care
less what anyone thought about me the
only people whose opinions i cared about
were people who had the lifestyle i
wanted to have in future and and that
was it like if you don't have the
lifestyle i want in three to five years
or you know the the results you have in
this particular field of discussion
isn't desirable to me then i have no
choice but to disregard your opinion
because i'll be doing myself a massive
disservice ultimately but it's such a
privilege to have um no it's not
appropriate it's a privilege to know
people that you want to be like not
everyone is in a in like a community
where they can look up to someone who
has a positive influence of what you
want to be
and like i get when you're an adult
you've got a choice where you live but
at the end when you're growing up like
you only know what you know yeah but i
became that influence for myself
do you think it's a privilege to be born
in 2022 where you're richer than most
people even the richest people were in
all of human history so even like poor
people today are richer than people were
in most of history you never know
because you don't know what it's going
to be like in 20 years no no but we know
but we know what's going on the last
like four thousand yeah yeah and so so
you could say being born in 2022 is much
better than being bored during the
plague
yeah yeah yeah
and so so it's all about perspective
right because like if anything
everybody's privileged in 2022. but i
think one of the reasons why people are
the most depressed in in these days and
times because we take the most
antidepressants we're the most anxious
we're the most depressed in the west is
because we have put we have put
expectations upon ourselves
right which are basically unrealistic
and so we get upset and you know we get
depressed by the fact that we can't
actually reach those expectations
whereas
you know if you go back
to the 60s 50s
40s people were happier
because people talk about especially
when it comes to women right people talk
about oh women had to they never had any
rights and they had to you know ask men
for everything they were happier they
won less antidepressants they were less
anxious
they were less there was less anxiety
there were there were less mental
illnesses in in the dsm yes but that's
because
feminine mental illness was defined as
hysteria and women were sent to like get
you know electrostatic therapy because
they were emotional and that's any kind
of mental illness was defined as that
it's not because it wasn't present it's
because we didn't have the words
instances of that a lot so you to use
that as the general rule
is a misnomer there were a lot more than
instances of it that was the majority of
women who expressed any sort of
emotionality beyond the point of what
was expected were defined as having
hysteria and were required or a witch
hysteria is an extension of that like we
have a history of like separating that
part from society the mental even the
feminine from society and kind of that
darker side of the feminine that's not
really understood it's demonized and
it's pushed out so hysteria was defined
and just because there's more words for
it now the darker side of the feminine
what you mean by that so this this is a
whole thing that i have a theory about
so it was kind of what i was saying
about the madonna and the [ __ ] how we
separate the two qualities of the
feminine where there's the extremely
sexual and there's the extremely pure
and then society has a way of kind of
dictating and governing that because
it's difficult to understand how they
can coexist together so in terms of like
when a woman
does things that aren't really
understood she's a witch or if she's
overly emotional which isn't understood
by the masculine typically you know i'm
not saying
going on a show with the guy
i'm not specifically referring to that
instant all right i'm like
i'll give her hysteria
i'll give it to her but it's it's weird
is we exaggerate those sides of
ourselves and it's we're pushed to and
i'm not making excuse for it at all
because yeah i agree that's it's not
great behavior but it's because we've
been um pushed to align ourselves with
one side either hypersexual or hyper
pure and it's because it's been
constantly separated over time that we
have to align ourselves with planet i'm
not saying it's a good thing
i'm not saying that's good at all but it
happens and i think it takes a certain
level of consciousness to be able to
step out of that which not a lot of
people have access so so to me i just
think girls like attention yep and so
but i'm saying i think girls especially
like we live off of attention that's why
so many girls are addicted to social
media where men are addicted to video
games would you say and so and so what i
would say is like girls that tend to be
more sexual got the attention from guys
and they liked it and they kept doing it
and that was like the positive feedback
loop but they didn't realize there was
consequences later and the girls that
didn't do that saw that there was
saw that they had the negative
consequences and therefore got the
positive feedback loop maybe had a dad
to tell them not to do it completely but
exactly you're giving it back to the
father if a father figure isn't present
to build that strong relationship with
masculine energy a woman is going to
seek out that attention that's true
that's true that's like daddy issues
yeah exactly yeah exactly
yeah we don't need the father anymore
but that's why that's what you need to
father that's why the father is so
important in the home remember right
yeah no when i i think the mask i don't
think it's necessarily a father i think
it's a healthy masculine representation
which is the problem and i think it
shouldn't necessarily be restricted to
it would you say in general or family
dynamic there are a lot of ways that
people can get those role models would
you say in general it's through a father
like a man yeah in
so general if we go back and forth about
exceptions we'll be talking in circles
all day but then the father has to step
up as well as the mother but i i think
men in general like men have issues too
i'm not i'm not negating that men have
issues but like i just think men are
there's a large group of men that have
no purpose because they don't have women
because modern women are side chicks
because modern women keep sleeping up
and up and up because you know damn well
that you could sleep with a guy that
would never be seen in public with you
ever like like that like yeah and it's
that's not fun but it's just true like
guys will have sex with a hole in the
wall right yeah guys
and you guys you ladies know that you
can be looking your words you can walk
out the house looking average and still
garner attention from it yeah men will
still give you attention
and so and so the thing is like if we
keep with birth control and the sexual
revolution it's a smaller percentage of
men that are having all the sex so that
means a larger percentage of men are
sleeping with nobody and and like that's
what i'm saying it starts with the women
because if women aren't creating
families
and i think it was rwanda or something
and it was basically looking at um who
like basically who got the women
and it would be the chief or whatever
they were called and then they would
have they would have multiple wives
you've seen that like all across the
world right that's never changed and
they did a study and they found that the
the first wife had the children with the
man and they were like the you know the
best they were like queen on top
children and then the other wives who
had
um babies with the a powerful man even
if they didn't have 100 exclusivity
those children were better off than
um if a woman had a baby and with a
monogamous man who wasn't so that's not
just in today's society that's literally
you're you're correct like you're
absolutely corrupt you could make an
argument for polygamy but the difference
was back then the women got resources
with it so it wasn't like like nowadays
you're just giving sex for free exactly
it's like back then you got you might
not have been first wife but you could
have been third or four like in in
muslim cultures we had a guy in here
that talked about how he had to marry
each and every wife of his and he had to
provide they were taken care of
financially forever
and so i'm not
i mean i don't i don't prefer the
polygamous stuff but if like someone
wants to do it you can make you can make
an argument for it yeah but the problem
is women are getting taking sex without
the resources
and so
and and so
and so therefore they're incentivized to
get a kid off of a rich guy
women women don't understand
that you set the standard yeah okay for
men to have sex okay and because men
generally as much as men men even know
we're quite simple creatures yeah if the
[ __ ] is there we'll go for it yeah okay
and if you have to understand that if
you're giving it away for free like
literally i can download the app right
now right and in an hour i can have sex
like sex is so readily available from
women yeah that men no longer have to
work for it if men had to work for sex
yeah we wouldn't have half of the
problems that we're having right now but
i think the thing is women are giving
away their vaginas so readily so easily
that men are like oh well you know i
don't have to work for it like what what
the hell i'm women and then we'll scream
men are trash but
we set the standards yeah you have to
leverage sexual assault commitment yeah
that's what it is you need to leverage
sexual access to get commitment right
just like a man you know leverages like
his commitment or his resources you know
whether that's physical protection
emotional security or financial security
in order to gain access like you need to
do or we need to do a better job of
leveraging sexual access to get
commitment because if you're giving it
away for free then why why am i going to
commit i can get it from free
and then you go on a talk show on a
dating show with a guy that's just had
sex with you right in the morning
talking about oh yeah you know what i
want to date a guy you just had a penis
inside you like because your vagina is
so readily available yeah you have to
understand uh seriously i think women
need to understand you are making your
vaginas too readily available okay and
then you cannot now complain that men
are trash because the bottom line is if
you don't set the standard if you don't
set the president because men listen men
will die through fire for [ __ ] i'm
telling you right they will die for the
fire for [ __ ]
ish knows right
dave has a song
don't die for nyan yeah
right exactly but the thing is if it's
if you make it less red because like i
said if dave chappelle said if [ __ ] was
a stock
right
it would it would plummet it would be
plummeting right now because the market
has been flooded with it right so you
have to understand that if you flood the
market with something it no longer
becomes precious i think i think it's a
bit of laziness it no longer becomes
precious
i think that's why vagina's not precious
anymore why is there a need for it to be
precious why isn't it like oh man men
have been confused
i think my body's precious sex is sex
it's something to do because you want to
enjoy it it's not because oh hey this is
like
what is this guy going to give me so i'm
going to give him this it's just like oh
i don't know one day i might want to
have sex i'll do it i don't know i don't
know about that you can create it
talking into your mind a little closer
yeah i prefer like you're not having sex
with me like as a woman personally like
you can just go out and be like i don't
know what sucks but like i if i like
definitely treat me like a princess
first like
don't just like you can't just enter and
leave
like i think
i don't want that you can't just go down
to the gas station have sex with me and
go back to my boyfriend but yes we can
yes yeah some women
are fine with that and that's their
prerogative and i don't think you should
if there's a you shouldn't control women
who want to do that and like
like make them feel bad about it because
that's you know there's a lot of people
with kinks out there men and women
involved
who are like into that but there's a lot
of trying to make them feel bad about
do you have the same do you have the
same energy for men that don't want to
date girls with high body counts do you
have the same energy like that's your
prerogative you're allowed to do what
you want to do
or because a lot of times when i see
yeah because a lot of times what i see
is like there'll be things like
slut-shaming and like shaming language
language when men want to have standards
but it's also like i don't think if if
you're a woman who doesn't sleep around
a lot i don't think you would want to
date a man who sleeps around a lot i
think you just probably find someone
who's on your level of shagging yeah but
a guy who sleeps around a lot is
definitely a guy who's provided value to
a particular extent because the vast
majority of guys can't do that you know
this is this is women are attracted to
men with sex experience exactly like you
because you deal with the best guys you
think all guys are like that whereas the
reality is that that's a very minute
percentage of men
no yeah the
i i've talked to i've had a lot of girls
on the show and typically they don't
want a virgin yeah would you like
[Laughter]
because i feel like if you're a virgin
like you're probably waiting for someone
special and like if you were to i think
it goes for me it goes both ways it's
like
oh like i'm not first
can i just add something can i just she
said try a virgin
novelty wait your dms are going to be
oh my god they're already going crazy
for me
princess treatment first no process and
then they're already in the chat they're
like they're wiper
like you would want a virgin man for a
long-term relationship yeah so you would
prefer to teach a man how to get sex in
the bedroom 100
i'd rather like him like um
i think it's more attract if a man is
too confident in chatting to me
leave because i know you've chatted to
10 girls in this club already like or
this bar whatever like it's too you're
too skilled at this right i want someone
who comes to me like
my last ex like the first kiss we had he
was like shaking a bit i was like you
okay it's like can i kiss you and i was
like this is the sweetest thing i think
it's the sweetest thing when someone's
like really nervous because obviously
like it's not like they don't do it all
the time so
i don't believe you yeah
i think this generation of women have
become so masculine yeah
that some feminine behaviors in men
actually turn them on wow
that is that is what i believe i believe
that so many women of this girl say this
generation have become so masculine that
men acting like women now turns them on
and it's very weird to me because it's
like i don't think it's acting like
women it is because it's like it's
expressing femininity
it is it's quite it's quite a feminine
everyone has sprung everyone has
masculine and feminine yeah
of course if you're varying different
degrees yeah if you're a man typically
this isn't exhaustive of course
typically you're gonna have more
masculine energy what do i look like
yeah
you ever think about when feminism
advocates for men it only advocates for
men to benefit them because they want
them to be more emotionally available
say that again whenever feminism
advocates for men they only advocate for
men when it benefits them because they
want men to be more emotionally
available so it's really about the women
it's not the man it's not big i would
ask you i would argue that being
emotionally available is good for
everyone yeah and not just especially if
you choose to have kids an emotionally
available man yeah it's a lot better
than an emotional thing i mean and you
would think that from a woman's point of
view yeah yeah because that that's like
yeah
let's ask the man yeah i've got a caveat
to that so
in an instance i agree with you but more
so than anything a man shouldn't be
emotionally available to his woman
because a woman more times than not
doesn't understand the complexities that
he goes through he should be emotionally
available to his male friends who he
should seek guidance from in order to
deal with the situations that
will come within his relationship and
i'm saying male friends that are
actually good and conducive to what he
wants and that way what happens is a
woman will feel emotionally
comfortable to come and open up to her
man
because
sh he's
he can be her rock yeah
i feel like women think they can see
that you see that guy that's a bit
nervous that wants to kiss you and was
like oh like oh my god i'm shy you see
that guy there you know that guy's not a
protector exactly somewhere in somewhere
in you you know that guy is a [ __ ] he
don't see a spider you do you do you
know that guy he's not confident he's
not confident um he doesn't really he
doesn't get girls he's not the type of
he does he's not the type of man he's
not the type of man that you step out in
public where they said okay this guy's
going to protect me he's not that dude
so at the end of it at the end of the
day it might be a novelty for a certain
point of so for a certain for a certain
time right but i think in the long run
you wouldn't even respect that man
or a second guy i'm just curious the
second guy so the one you laughed
at the result
that's not because of it it's actually
he was
we
i don't want to say him online
you don't have to do it but that's not
the reason like
that's the reason i started dating him
and it's not that if he was like
there's boys who are very confident and
that turns me right off like it's the
complete opposite it's just a lot of
times like what guy the feedback because
i listen to men talk a lot and so a lot
of times what they say is like when what
don't listen to what women say because
they'll say things watch what they do
and so so and this is the case where
you're saying this man was emotionally
available but the result was still you
laughing it doesn't mean yeah it doesn't
mean he was emotionally available like
that's a complete like
i don't know but that's not the thing is
the thing is grossly underestimate the
plaque man they think they can actually
solve his problems but like
especially for feminine exactly
especially from an emotional point of
view like you you really don't
and can't to a certain extent understand
the plight of a man and how what it's
like for people to only value you based
on what you can provide on a continual
basis yeah another man can understand
that because he's in the exact same
situation so if a man can actually you
know process his emotions using his
other male friends who are let's say
further down the line let's say these
men have successful marriages he can
then go back to his let's say newly
married wife and be like okay cool this
is how it's going to be this is he can
he knows exactly what to say and how to
move and how to maneuver right because
he's gotten that tutelage from older
experienced men who let's say are in
successful maritime relationships i
really do think that women should not
run societies
why because return our rights baby
because you want to feminize men yeah
and you think you think feminine men are
gonna listen china and russia are still
around yeah a bunch of feminine men
running around ain't gonna be good for
society because when it's wartime you
can have a bunch of [ __ ] running
around saying oh my god baby could you
go out and do the war no like what the
hell you need masculine men for an
actual reason and i think when women are
in charge they use their emotions more
so than they use their logic and so they
ask men to be like them which is why
when a woman women generally come to men
to have a conversation and say oh my god
babe you're not happy at work today and
a man just like
because he you should talk to your women
friends like that i get it right but men
do not operate the same way you so how
would you
love your wife or whoever you're dating
to operate with you in the home
how would i do what how would you prefer
her to operate with you in the home
if she's
just provide value and be an asset yeah
but how that's so vague like okay cool
like okay so if you want to would you
talk to her at all
okay so this is the thing i'm writing it
down okay so women women have a way in
which they speak to each other yeah so
you see earlier on when you said the
communication wasn't communicating yeah
right i'm like what the [ __ ]
like so women have a certain language
that they have between one another right
and so what you have to understand is
men operate
mentally and oh what the hell is that
like men operate differently right when
it comes to um
understanding and when it comes to
processing information but very logical
like i said if i'm gonna talk to you bro
i'm gonna tell you this this this this
this boom done right women are like when
a woman speaks to you she told me about
her feelings first all right so i was
anyway i was on my period right so you
already know
and it's like it's a whole thing and i'm
and i'm just like
i ain't got men generally don't have
time for that type of conversation they
generally don't and i know you you're
probably thinking this is misogynistic
this is sexist but but it's real like
men don't operate we don't speak like
you speak we don't communicate like you
communicate exactly what you want to do
babe call i'll see you later then right
exactly
i'll leave you to it it's interesting
what you said because like you use the
word misogynistic and i think a lot of
women conflate you know someone trying
to let them know that their actions will
have long-term consequences and
ramifications with you hate me because
right now i'm feeling like you hate me
no i don't hate you i'm just thinking
about your long-term growth and
development right that's a completely
different thing you might be feeling
like i hate you in this moment but
really what i'm telling you is going to
be good for you long term you know and
yeah i was in a relationship for like 10
years right and i i remember
specifically
repeatedly
being
being fed a story and i'm listening for
the end of the story and i'm like okay
cool
what we can do after this do you know
what i mean like you tell and and
literally i learned that women just like
to vent
it's not necessarily that you want to
have a conclusion to the end you just
like to vent but i'm looking at it like
okay cool that happened i'm gonna fix it
like this
no but that's not i just wanted to talk
i just you just want to vent and i'm
like we don't communicate like that
literally like men don't communicate
that when we vent we vent to our other
men exactly
i feel like we can't as well because you
know like that's time you know
yeah it's like we just communicate
differently i just think we need to stop
calling people misogynistic and
patriarchal all those kind of stuff and
just understand that we are wired
differently our brains are wired
differently i feel like it's a
generalization and you're also missing
out people who don't really conform to
any sort of gender norms and people who
aren't with someone who of an opposite
gender
and it's i don't know like you say women
do this women do that but
there are women who take the masculine
role in relationships to fulfill that
role and and men still have feminine
energies even if you want to deny and
repress it out of them they still have
that emotional body and just because
they don't necessarily have the same
language communicated it's still there
and having that emotional space to be
vulnerable with each other is so
important in a relationship you can't be
vulnerable with the person you're with
women like yourself are creating
feminine men that's my point
you're creating oh yeah in my opinion
you know masculine men start wars so i'd
rather the feminine who doesn't start
the war if i'm honest women women have
started more wars you yeah men start a
lot of wars because of bloody women
because of women it's the men starting
it still though just because a woman has
caused it because a man you know helen
of troy and whatnot over beauty and all
that but now but when you say that when
you say you want like the masculine the
wit sometimes the women take the
masculine world but that's not the
natural not necessarily with a man
sometimes with a woman as well
the man who's a bit more feminine so
what if a woman was transgender and she
transitioned then she's not naturally
like a man so then what is that bad
say that again so if a woman is feminine
a woman
uh whatever she maybe comes to
realization or she thought her whole
life and then she transitions and now
she's a man she's not a natural she's
not a man she's not she's
a biological female she's a biological
female it's not a man you're female
doesn't but gender i mean you're right i
don't like the way you're saying it from
in the sense of she's like they are they
are biological females it's a biological
perspective but you're talking about
this woman
is still there
what i'm saying is you think that a man
who doesn't behave manly is wrong so a
man who transitions to a woman and then
behaves
womanly is he wrong
is that is that bad for society is that
yes detrimental yes because
okay so if we flipped it right if we
said all the women in society now
masculine and the men now act feminine
how do you think society would run
but it's not all men and women no i'm
just saying because you think it's okay
so i'm saying if you flip the rules if
you say all women act like men and all
men and black women how do you think
society's going that's just
not realistic that doesn't answer what
i'm saying but you didn't answer what i
said
you're saying i'm saying if you said if
a transgender yeah
if
a biological make it make sense to me if
a biological man yep became a woman
became a you can't become a woman but
okay become a woman
and then was behaving girly girly is
that wrong
but is it wrong is it bad for society is
that what it is it is well then your
views are just
of course it's wrong
what's more silly what's more silly than
a man thinking that he's a woman
oh oh wow
silly like isn't it so completely
unfathomable it just wouldn't exist like
it exists and there's there's a spectrum
of gender right and people choose what
how
right are you
feeling are you telling me that i can be
a woman i'm asking you
because there's a difference between
being male and female and being a man
and a woman get me out of here
masculinity debate is it not
conversation
are you a woman sorry it was like it was
a friend of mine
it's just a phrase yeah you're a woman
yeah so i could be you
no you couldn't be me because i'm a
person you're a person no but i'm saying
i could be your gender
yeah if you wanted to change it yeah
it's about it's about masculinity and
femininity people can embody those roles
it doesn't have to be your gender
serious serious seriousness
i feel like in the context of this
conversation we're talking about the
masculine and feminine roles and women
is a name for gender not sex that
someone can identify themselves with no
matter what because it depends on your
spirit your soul your mind your body
everything
how it works so how would you know if
someone's a male or a female i wouldn't
i would ask them you would ask them but
like could you make generalizations
about who's who you could have female
font change no i couldn't yeah if you
talk about sex you're right but we talk
about men and women yeah and i would say
based on masculinity and femininity and
if you say that all women become men in
terms of fulfilling that masculine role
that masculine role is still oh i just
thought we couldn't generalize
sorry i really you might not be able to
afford the surgery yet no i'll hold up
right over here you might just want to
keep that you might be intersecting my
hands are off sorry sorry before one at
a time guys people at home can't hear i
want everyone to hear something yeah
we'll get back to it sorry let me just
get back to this because this is
something that really like it grinds my
gears right you're telling me that as a
man who has been biologically born a man
with a penis and two testicles you're
telling me that i can be a woman
yes if you want and you're and you're
now telling me also that a woman that
you with breast a womb vagina you can be
a man if you're out there and you want
to you can yes you can no no
how i think it could be a remix any way
that you want
you can get it done i'm a man yeah right
i know what is it man we got three men
in here there's absolutely no way you
could be us we know that as men there's
no way you could be us i could identify
as a man i don't care what he identifies
you're not a man
cool it doesn't matter what you identify
as i feel the man so you going off on
this round has told me that everything
that you've said before that was also
prejudice and bias and i really don't
respect any opinion that comes out of
your mouth i don't mind right
i'm gonna i'm gonna come at this from a
different level and say that i'm
actually non-binary and there are points
where i fulfill a feminine role and
there are points where i fulfill a
masculine role and i switch between
those energies and both feel equally um
comfortable to me and equally like i'm
not saying i could transition to a man
because i'm not transgender but it's
about the masculinity and the femininity
which transcends sex do you have a
vagina
yes i do
business
by this logic can i identify as black
yeah oh my god
not completely why not not the same
thing why not because it's it's it's
it's it's racist that's how i feel
that's how i feel because
i feel racist
i can identify as pearl because i can
identify as a white woman that's silly
we don't know it's something that's
someone else
no it's intense we don't distinguish if
we talk about roles in society we don't
distinguish roles by race we distinguish
roles as apparently by this conversation
through you know um
through gender right sexuality um
femininity masculinity that's how we
define roles we don't do that by race
okay i identify as a dog then woof
is really really really funny
that is really funny
i am afraid
right i'm african by genetics you're
female by genetics you know that right
right so so yeah there's no way in i'm
not a woman by genetics i'm a woman by
choice by a social construct
you're one by genetics you've got an
ex-expert female female female social
constructs
they're
tell me what a woman isn't
are you also a woman is someone that
says i am a woman
wow
um i also think
everyone's talking in the binary is that
that you can either be a man or a woman
you can't be like in between there's in
between where like you can be like oh
god willie but i really am feminine and
i love
typically feminine things and you know i
want to address a feminine way that
doesn't it may not even necessarily mean
that you want to transition or whatever
you could just be a bit of a girly man
do you know what you just said you just
said as long as you say what you are you
are that yeah but listen
when i'm she wants to define when i'm
with a woman right i fulfill a more
masculine role like that's just kind of
a natural energy with a man i fulfill a
more feminine role it's just how i
naturally switch between the two right
both of those are equally like valuable
parts of myself right it's just
different energies that are expressed at
different times the masculine and the
feminine side and people have different
levels of them some are more masculine
and some are more feminine and they
fulfill that role it doesn't it's not
determined by biological sex it's just
not it can be but it's it's it's gender
is a construct right and we have
different degrees of masculine and
feminine energies in us you probably
have more masculine and that's fine but
other people men especially do have more
feminine energy and there shouldn't be a
judgment on that everyone has their role
in society everywhere has their place i
also think it's way more accepted if
you're a masculine woman in society
because masculinity is so like valued
and revered but if you're a bit of a
feminine man yeah you're a [ __ ] or
aurora where it's like actually that's
fine like you can you can also
i think it's it's it's accepted yeah
it's it's it's
it's it's accepted by other women but
it's not accepted by men do you know
what they have if their job is not going
to be feminine
and then they match i mean typically
typically the guys that typically the
guys that like masculine women are are
usually
male males they're usually yeah like i
mean the girls don't even like him
the girls like it's like those girls
that hate their husbands because they
have him by the balls
like this is what and i know you're
thinking of someone but why are we
creating femininity with like being
submissive
and being like that
there's nothing wrong with that that's
part of it
that's again i think that's more of the
social context that's more the social
construct that we've built into the
feminine is submissive in the mat
one second
again oh i think that's part of the
social construct that we've built and
the feminine has to be submissive like
it goes back to um we like again the
separation of the power of the feminine
from her submissive nature right women
are powerful they are powerful right and
they don't have to be submissive and
relationships not about submission
but being being feminine is is following
so so because men lead typically
throughout all of human history men have
led and women follow and men can't lead
if there's no one following you can't
lead when there's no one following at
the end
at the end at the end of the day
somebody has to lead a relationship
someone has to do it you can't both lead
yeah so when at the end of the day when
there's a decision someone has to make
it if you guys disagree so part of
femininity is following the man i would
argue that that's in the patriots
patriarchal society that we've built
which i'm not saying is wrong but i'm
not i'm also saying that it's not
unreasonable to assume that the woman
can lead as well i think actually women
are biological
lead together biological mention and
female sports
people like leah thomas
maybe they should make well it's a new
thing isn't it we haven't tried it
before so maybe we'll make a new
category for people who don't fall
within those categories well so okay so
obviously
no i said no why would we have a
category if they're a woman right the
question i asked was specific
should biological men enter female
sports no i don't think so
and i would agree with that but i think
it's because obviously um you know why
why if they're women because remember
you said that a man can actually be a
woman so if
you don't think biological men can enter
female sports you are by default saying
that you don't think they're actually
the same they're not females that one
context is a big fat anomaly in this
debate because like that's really big
reliance
and there's a gender and then there's
biological difference right so if you're
a sport and you've changed your gender
you're still probably be a lot bigger
like taller whatever but also coming
back to the submissive point um
because i wanted to get that in there i
think
today like submissive is seen as a
negative thing and women have to be
powerful and strong and like what's
wrong with being submissive i think
there's nothing wrong with being
submissive and i think you know
i think yeah completely
if no one is but in today's society like
you have to be your own boss and you
have to be a boss lady like maybe maybe
i don't want to be a boss yeah if no one
is submissive then certain missions just
won't be accomplished
there is space for people to be
submissive of course there is but
there's also space for people to lead
together it doesn't have to be the
blanket term that women should be
submissive and meant to take the same
together that that sounds great ideally
but when it comes to practicalities
it doesn't work
it doesn't work i mean if it worked then
we would have one like mike how many
kings are there one might be five kings
well that's just a case of ego isn't it
because no they can't hear you they
can't eat mike thank you all right we'll
get back to it it's a case of utility
and functionality and what actually
works as opposed to what we
romanticize and idealize yeah does
anyone really lead in today's society
though like
we're all being led like there's no men
that are leading women it's all we're
all being led by
exactly like that like always a ceo
there's always a manager there's always
and that is not to say that your job if
you're not a manager if you're a bit
lower isn't as important it's so
important but you need a leader in a
business for the business to run
relationships without organization
you've got nothing you could be the most
skilled thing yeah we're talking about
relationships they're not businesses
i think there is a level of like there
is kind of a business like you have to
run a house you have to pay rent you
have to make sure the food's cooked like
it is you have to organize things like
the same way you would a business
so you need to have a head and a deputy
head or something like that or these
people maybe two but maybe a partner at
the top but this is this is what this is
this is what feminism lies they say you
can have everything you can't have
everything you can't you can't have it
all it's about sacrifices it's about
choices and trade-offs that's about
sacrifice one thing i want to add is the
girls said that um
having feminine men
isn't really a problem in society and
i want to kind of counteract that and
say that
issues that you would have with feminine
men is they can't control their emotions
like women can we all know that women
are very good when it comes to the
emotional control in in con in most in
general
i'm sorry in general we're using
generalities however you'll find that if
men can't control their emotions they
become irrational if a man becomes
irrational
you could find himself lashing out
men are physically stronger than women
in general so an emotional man
you'll find if he's unable to control
his emotion because he's in his feminine
yeah and not in his masculine where he
knows he has to think 10 steps ahead to
make the right decision being a feminine
he's in his emotions men are not used to
you controlling their emotions you might
find he'll lash out and do things that
are not conducive to a good relationship
but controlling and regulating your
choice if you want to regulate your
behavior that is your choice obviously a
lot everyone lashes out from time to
time but people have limits people know
what their limits are what they will and
will not do if you're a man and you
can't control your temper you can't
blame it on the femininity you need to
sort yourself out
the difference between a man lashing now
and a woman lashing out is if a woman
lashes out and hits a man
not not much could happen in most
scenarios if a man lashes out and hits a
woman there's a possibility that if he
in his rage can't control his power he
could kill her
and honestly
when i go out and i'm doing street
interviews i'm not afraid of men i'm
afraid of women every time every time
i've been threatened by someone it is a
hundred percent been a woman it's never
happened to me
in in context of both regulating
controlling your emotions is a learned
behavior right it's a sophisticated
learned behavior women don't always have
the ability to regulate their emotions
they have to learn that men can do the
same it's not impossible it's a learned
behavior right and and it might be have
a greater intensity sure but they
probably also have like
the same capacity to be able to pull
that back women have intense emotions
you know they lash out and react
differently but that intensity is still
there and we're controlling that and
regulating that is 100 learned some
people learn it early on with the you
know parent figures parental figures can
teach them that some people have to
learn it later on but essentially it's a
learned behavior like especially if you
feel intensely no one comes in this
world able to navigate their emotions
and experiences it's confusing but the
thing is there's consequences for men
there's not for women yeah exactly
there's that's that's the whole thing
but i would just like no because like
look what happened with johnny depp and
amber heard she still hasn't even been
convicted that's the crazy thing she did
all that like it's just a civil suit
it's not even
if that if it was vice versa johnny depp
would be in jail if that happened to a
man with power privilege and money
what happens to the average guy
and if you look at um
abusive relationships where both people
where it's one-sided meaning one side's
hitting and the other side is not the
majority of those are women hitting men
it's 70 percent
and emotional men have a high
probability of ending up in prison for
good
reason agree physical abuse is very high
within lesbian relationships also yeah
so then i would agree the issue is still
like learning how to regulate and
control your behaviors and it's not
restricted to either gender right
more feminine
who's lashing out but then you're
talking about women who are physically
lashing out isn't the issue the same on
both sides where they're just not
regulating their behaviors so i agree
with your point the only thing i want to
add to that sorry i need to use my
camera because we've just bought it you
know
yeah shout out shout out i agree with
you the only thing that we are genuinely
trying to say
is that there are consequences or the
consequences are far greater for a man
who does the same thing as a woman yeah
in these situations i would say that
there are situations where like if you
was to hit me people will look and go uh
not a problem yeah if i hit you
back
in retaliation
i could get rushed
you can get arrested
i was in shoreditch one time one girl
tried to show me a um a move that um she
had learned so she put my hand like that
i went aloft i had five guys surround me
in case i reacted and i was like wait a
minute so how did this happen i
completely agree with you and i think
that's again with the transition in
society where we've shifted to you know
feminism and and that sort of thing like
radical feminism kind of comes in and we
have to support the woman and stuff but
like i said women were you know sent to
mental asylums just for being a little
bit emotional in the past and i'm not
saying this is a justification of that
but it's like we've almost gone the
other way and it's about pulling that
back so i'm not saying i agree with that
necessarily but i just think it's
possible to be able to regulate it so
that doesn't happen and first we have to
look at it and
do you ever think you look at history
very one-sided because like on the other
side of that men were sent to a war yeah
so it's like it's like we kind of look
at women as victims throughout all of
history but but men were the ones that
had to build societies and sacrifice
their lives to do it like do you know
how the u.s was started
they kidnapped a group of men basically
and just sent them over from from
england that's how australia was yeah
and they said deal with it most of them
died they tried to do it with women and
they're like oh no we can't do that to
women like they're too valuable let's
let's leave them here take the meds i
think men and women have faced equal
persecution in different ways and i
think that's more about the thing i
think it's we've been victims in
different ways right i don't think it's
about taking away that side from the men
but also acknowledging what women have
been through and now we're kind of
flipped and reversed the roles right and
it's about kind of finding that middle
ground where we don't do that where we
don't victimize either side so i
wouldn't i would completely agree i
completely agree with you okay so we
agree
yeah i can i can do some super chats
guys like the video that is the most
important metric on this
on this stream also guys
we are trying to get a
fifth camera in here we're also trying
to get new lighting so sun super chats
it helps with the show also we're trying
to move in october so sign up for our
memberships that way um we can maybe get
a bigger place and do a couple different
rooms that people can stream from
also guys um
be nice in the chat okay be nice
okay um
mary handel imagine kicking indoors in
iraq during g-w-o-t for this matt
butcher case study let's put a bunch of
women who don't believe in hierarchies
on an island and see how that pans out
um the real
samocho
if i mate with a man and he gets
pregnant did his feminine energy allow
him to get pregnant
okay um
kennedy love the show look up john money
originator of gender as a social
construct idea new germ new term
identity grubber one without the
fullness or purpose that must adopt
one of the positions
wait hold on i'm sorry i can't read
sometimes all right love the show look
up john money originator of the gender
as social construct idea new term
identity grubber one without fullness or
purpose that must adopt one of these
positions to have all to have something
at their core
the fallen they have fallen into a
rabbit hole they don't want to accept
the new reality reality is a construct
now that's from why so serious gaming um
victor our army our menta feminine men
in war versus masculine men eat in war
equals losing the war for feminine men
make making countries more feminine as
bad as countries who wouldn't do the
same for leaving your country at a loss
because of war um
i identity is different than sex please
explain how we could recognize male from
female from an ancient skeleton pearl
thanks for asking what is a woman you
guys are the best
um
sofa spy gender is about biological
reproduction period not what your
feelings are being politically correct
if you can't get payment then you if you
can't get pregnant then you're not a
woman um sentient spectrum of gender so
binary versus
non-binary
so binary versus non-binary to include a
rainbow of genders correct if you get
your head out of your delusional asses
you would actually realize that binary
is two choices and binary versus nine
non-binary is also two choices um
sheldon ross you guys talk about china
and all the steps they're going through
to bring masculinity back to their
country um i've never heard of that but
maybe i'll look into it i don't know
sentience i'm talking about female
hysteria and repressed female
promiscuity throughout the ages 1960s to
now we have unbonded the female
sexuality and yielded broken women to
sub
subsequent children
um um johnny be a hundred dollar super
child let's go
these women are why you fellas can't
change their things fix them they have
their place in society just wear
protection when you deal with them once
they serve their purpose and you want to
settle down a bit find yourself a soft
feminine woman with role models or with
strong morals
andrew cruz question i'm a 30 year old
male in california have been single for
nine years sixth generation family
farmer i work 40 to 7 hours 40 to 70
hours a week
and women have not even noticed me in
five years how am i supposed to change
this i don't have time for bs what do
you think sarah
how does he's what he's 30 years old
yeah he's 30 he's uh he works 40 to 70
hours a week as a farmer for nine years
he's a sixth generation generation
family farmer and women don't notice him
how can he he's probably working too
much yeah he's probably not socializing
enough yeah 70 hours a week yeah god
damn
sentience you are not valued by how much
money you make as a woman in society
most self-sufficient men do not care
about how much money you might make men
value youth fertility beauty morals
chastity loyalty and femininity
femininity from the women that they seek
sean jackson most men aren't sleeping
around like this it's the minority of
men that want that want to be and don't
qualify for that but they are it's maybe
15 to 20 at best zero fallout 45 single
mother rate in america this is what
feminism has done for the west over 50
years has proven women can't choose the
right man glad social media is around
because the younger men can see what us
older gents have been saying for a long
time um taurian pearl do you realize
that what ninja watcher means
it doesn't mean a sneaky person looking
at oh no what have i been saying it
doesn't mean a sneaky person looking at
you just wanting to know in case you are
not aware also kudos to your rise um
real fun sapien shout out to my friend
ally
in the house
that's my house boyfriend
you know what this is for um i do i do
know what this is for um and then that's
pretty much all the super chats i'm
sorry guys there was a lot today i tried
to get through all of them but
um why don't we you know
yeah wrap up the show okay okay
um so why don't two hours now yeah so
why don't we go around um everyone can
say any final thoughts where the people
can find you
anything yeah okay cool uh yeah my name
is jay johnson you can find me on
instagram jay johnson official that's j
ay johnson with an h and then official i
like to uh yeah i can produce all kinds
of music but i like to keep it jazzy and
fresh you know play guitar keys pace
drums and yeah i think personal
development taking ownership and
responsibility for your actions i think
is very important if it wasn't for that
sort of mentality definitely wouldn't be
where i am today so yeah hit me up if
you like that kind of vibe
hello uh yes my name is simona you can
find me on instagram if you search my
name simona kudafani if you can figure
out how to spell it um i want to just
say that i think in this society
especially in modern day that you can
choose to be and fulfill any role that
you decide to and that should there
shouldn't be any biological restrictions
on that what i personally believe
i'm a musician too so if you want to
follow me and check that out that'd be
cool all right
i was about to say hello i'm georgia
um i'm on tick tock as georgia paints as
in she does paintings
and i talk a lot and i encourage
everyone to mind their own business and
not talk about other people ever because
it's rude
i just think everyone peace love
happiness and if i sound ignorant
i love it
uh hi everyone uh or goodbye everyone
once again my name is sophia
i think in my wrapping up thoughts of
this i think from the beginning i can
agree that we live in a broken society
i don't think
that necessarily any of the issues today
we're the cause of it i think that there
are many many causes of this broken
society so
um be whoever the [ __ ] you want to be
and just spread that love you know how
it is
hi i hired again you can find me on
instagram boredom
underscore ily
i sing i make clothes i write stories i
take photos and
i love socks and
uh what else um
you know what
i don't know about today's society i
feel like people are gonna do them and
they'll find out the consequences in it
so
all you can do is
just live and let live um there's also
one more there's a 50 super chat i'm
just going to give kudos um if i date a
man and he becomes pregnant did his oh
wait i read this one
i thought i thought it was i thought
there was one more let me just refresh
it i'm not trying to i'm trying i'm not
trying to
um just i try to give kudos to the big
super chatters just to make sure
the 50 oh no okay i did that one again
we're okay my final thoughts are um
yes i believe society is broken
um i believe there's a lot of delusion
going around
i believe there's a lot of people living
in their feelings and not dealing with
facts and statistics and logic and
rationale and reason
um i think some of it was displayed
today on the show personally and i think
if society is going to get any better we
are going to have to get out of our
feelings and we are going to have to
move forward into something a little bit
more stable
and
i hope we can do that into the future
and i thank all the guests for coming on
even if we did disagree yeah and we did
get a little bit heated um i think uh
stuff like this
the great area
is the place to be able to agree to
disagree if we do and also have
different opinions and still go home and
live our lives
well
yeah um no i really appreciate you guys
coming i know we don't agree on
everything but i honestly think it makes
a better show when we have when
it's better when we disagree rather than
everyone just having the same opinion
and i think we had a uh do we have a
record high in terms of viewership
[Music]
so i think we had um 3600
at its highest point yeah yeah from what
i saw and i think our highest before was
three so yeah so that was amazing shout
out to you so thank you guys yeah yeah
thank you yeah let's get a round of
applause round of applause for everyone
um thank you guys so much for watching
do not forget to like the video on your
way out that is the most important
metric for youtube so
subscribe to the channel as well follow
the twitch page follow the facebook page
follow my instagram just dot pearly
things also if you want to get on the
show dm eddie his link is in the
description um also if you have a show
topic that you want to see there is a
link that you can submit a show topic as
well that is in i don't think we put it
in the description of this but if you go
to my instagram you can go on there and
you can submit a show topic
um on top of that we also have a new
clips channel so go follow the new clips
channel that is in the description as
well oh and pearl they're going to be
continuously asking when you when you
make the clips can you put the full link
to the video over there they keep asking
for they keep asking yeah i don't even
post them it's like a team i'm not i
don't i don't do it
we'll we'll get it we'll talk we'll talk
we'll talk um okay guys like the video
on your way out thank you for watching
and we'll talk to you next time peace
peace